Hey Torontonians, recycling is more than a routine. It's a vital responsibility. By recycling properly, you help conserve resources, reduce energy use in greenhouse gas emissions, and protect the environment. Toronto's Blue Bin Recycling Program ensures the majority of the right items are recovered and transformed into new products. Recycling right is important and impactful. Let's work together and make a difference, because small actions lead to big change.
多伦多的居民们，回收利用不仅仅是一种日常习惯，更是一项至关重要的责任。通过正确地进行回收，您可以帮助节约资源，减少温室气体排放带来的能源消耗，并保护环境。多伦多的蓝色回收箱计划确保了大部分可回收物品能够被回收并转化为新产品。正确回收既重要又具有影响力。让我们携手合作，做出改变，因为微小的行动也能带来巨大的变化。
For more tips on recycling, visit toronto.ca slash recycle right. Did you know that across Ontario, utility damage happens 19 times a day? That's over 4,222 incidents a year. Don't let your next dig be one that causes costly delays or safety risks. Before you break ground, make it a point to request a locate. It's not just the law, it's a step to keep your team and community safe. Visit ontarioonecall.ca and avoid unnecessary damages to get the job done right. Data sourced from the ORCGA 2023 Dirt Report.
如需了解更多回收建议，请访问 toronto.ca/recycle-right。您知道吗？在安大略省，平均每天发生 19 起公用设施损坏事故，一年超过 4,222 起。不要让您的下一次挖掘造成昂贵的延误或安全隐患。在动工之前，请务必申请地下管线定位。这不仅是法律要求，更是保障您的团队和社区安全的必要步骤。请访问 ontarioonecall.ca，避免不必要的损坏，确保工作顺利完成。数据来源：ORCGA 2023 年挖掘报告。
Some stories are so profound, so unimaginable, that they stay with us forever. The Unthinkable is the latest podcast from Casefile Presents, hosted by two of Australia's leading voices in true crime, Vicky Petratus and Emily Webb. The series delves into tales of ordinary people who have faced extraordinary, often devastating events and emerged forever changed. From survivors of traumatic events to victims of relentless stalking and even those who've confronted some of Australia's most notorious criminals, The Unthinkable explores the depths of human resilience. The first two episodes feature the incredible story of Louisa Hope, a woman who survived
有些故事深刻而不可思议，以至于让我们久久难以忘怀。《不可思议》（The Unthinkable）是 Casefile Presents 推出的最新播客，由澳大利亚两位顶尖的真实犯罪节目主持人维基·佩特拉图斯（Vicky Petratus）和艾米丽·韦伯（Emily Webb）主持。该系列深入探讨了普通人面对非凡且往往是毁灭性事件，并从此彻底改变命运的故事。从创伤事件的幸存者到遭受持续跟踪的受害者，甚至那些与澳大利亚最臭名昭著的罪犯对峙过的人，《不可思议》探索了人类韧性的深度。前两集讲述了路易莎·霍普（Louisa Hope）不可思议的故事，她是一位幸存者，
Sydney's Lindt Cafe siege in 2014. Both episodes will be available for free on Sunday November 10 wherever you get your podcasts, with episodes dropping weekly after that. Be sure to follow The Unthinkable so you don't miss an episode. Stay tuned until the end of today's episode to hear the trailer. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website.
经历了 2014 年悉尼林特咖啡馆（Lindt Cafe）的人质劫持事件。这两集将于 11 月 10 日星期日免费上线，您可以在任何获取播客的平台上收听，之后每周更新一集。请务必关注《不可思议》，以免错过任何一集。请收听今天节目的结尾，届时将播放预告片。我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看您应用中或我们网站上本集的节目说明。
When 23-year-old Duncan McPherson left his hometown of Saskatoon, Canada for a new job in Scotland in August 1989, his parents weren't worried. From a young age, Duncan had always shown incredible bravery and independence. He was just three years old when he first insisted on taking the bus to a doctor's appointment all by himself. The bus driver had refused to pick him up on account of his age, but that didn't deter the toddler. He simply figured out how to get on another bus instead. This level of courage and determination followed Duncan into his teenage years, bolstered by his strong physical stature. He developed a passion for ice hockey and spent years honing his skills, becoming a prized defenceman for the Saskatoon Blades where he earned the nickname
1989 年 8 月，23 岁的邓肯·麦克弗森（Duncan McPherson）离开家乡加拿大萨斯卡通，前往苏格兰开始新工作时，他的父母并不担心。邓肯从小就表现出惊人的勇敢和独立。他三岁时就曾坚持要独自一人乘公交车去赴约看医生。尽管公交车司机因他年龄太小而拒绝让他上车，但这并没有阻挡这个蹒跚学步的孩子。他只是想办法换乘了另一辆车。这种勇气和决心伴随着邓肯度过了青少年时期，并因他强健的体魄而得到加强。他培养了对冰球的热爱，并花费多年磨练技术，成为萨斯卡通刀锋队（Saskatoon Blades）的一名宝贵后卫，在那里他赢得了绰号
McPherson. His hard work paid off in 1984 when, at the age of 18, he was picked in the first round by the New York Islanders as part of the National Hockey League professional draft. This meant a move across the border into the United States, away from the comfort of his close-knit family. For five years, Duncan devoted his life to the game before the team cut him loose. He wasn't too disappointed though. While he adored ice hockey, he had no interest in the politics that went on behind the scenes in the Major League. Duncan told his mother he was happy to be moving on and ready for the next step in his life.
“麦克弗森”。他的努力在 1984 年得到了回报，当时 18 岁的他在国家冰球联盟（NHL）职业选秀中被纽约岛人队（New York Islanders）在第一轮选中。这意味着他要跨越边境前往美国，远离他亲密家庭的舒适环境。邓肯将五年的生命奉献给了这项运动，直到球队将他解雇。不过，他并没有太失望。虽然他热爱冰球，但他对大联盟幕后的政治毫无兴趣。邓肯告诉母亲，他很高兴能继续前进，并为人生下一阶段做好了准备。
He accepted a well-paid job as the head coach for the Dundee Tigers ice hockey team in Scotland and left Canada for Europe on Wednesday August 2 1989. On Friday August 11, Duncan's mother Linda MacPherson woke up in the middle of the night screaming. Her husband Bob was sleeping beside her and was roused by the commotion. He tried to calm Linda down, assuring her she'd just had a bad dream. Linda down, assuring her she'd just had a bad dream. But Linda's instincts told her otherwise. Something terrible has happened to Duncan was a week earlier on Friday August 4 1989. He'd called home to let his family know that he'd arrived safe in Germany where he was staying with his close friend George Peschut.
他接受了一份高薪工作，担任苏格兰邓迪老虎队（Dundee Tigers）的冰球主教练，并于 1989 年 8 月 2 日星期三离开加拿大前往欧洲。8 月 11 日星期五，邓肯的母亲琳达·麦克弗森（Linda MacPherson）在半夜尖叫着醒来。她的丈夫鲍勃（Bob）睡在她身边，被骚动惊醒。他试图安抚琳达，向她保证她只是做了一个噩梦。但琳达的直觉告诉她并非如此。邓肯一定发生了什么可怕的事情。一周前的 1989 年 8 月 4 日星期五，他曾打电话回家，告诉家人他已安全抵达德国，正与好友乔治·佩舒特（George Peschut）住在一起。
Duncan told his mother he was exhausted from the long international journey. While he was unsure of his exact plans, he said he was going to spend some time travelling and relaxing before his coaching job with the Dundee Tigers officially commenced on Monday August 14. Duncan promised Linda that he'd touch base with her again when he arrived in Scotland on Saturday August 12. The day after Linda's nightmare, she eagerly waited for that call. Something in her gut was telling her that Duncan was not okay. Even when he'd been living in America,
邓肯告诉母亲，长途国际旅行让他精疲力竭。虽然他不确定具体的计划，但他打算在 8 月 14 日星期一正式开始邓迪老虎队的主教练工作之前，花些时间旅行和放松。邓肯向琳达承诺，他会在 8 月 12 日星期六抵达苏格兰时再次与她联系。琳达做噩梦后的第二天，她焦急地等待着那个电话。她内心深处有一种预感，邓肯出事了。即使当他住在美洲时，
he never went more than a few days without checking in with his parents. That gnawing fear only intensified when the Macphersons still hadn't heard from Duncan by Monday August 14, the day he was scheduled to start his job with the Dundee Tigers. In the days before the internet and cell phones, it wasn't easy to make contact with overseas travellers. For days, Linda sat by the phone, urging it to ring. She tried to reassure herself that Duncan was probably just busy with his new job and would be in touch soon. On Wednesday August 16, the phone finally rang.
他从未超过几天不与父母联系。当 8 月 14 日星期一，也就是邓肯原定开始在邓迪老虎队工作的那天，麦克弗森夫妇仍未收到邓肯的消息时，那种啃噬内心的恐惧感愈发强烈。在互联网和手机普及之前的日子里，与海外旅行者取得联系并不容易。琳达守在电话旁好几天，祈祷它能响起来。她试图安慰自己，邓肯可能只是忙于新工作，很快就会联系。8 月 16 日星期三，电话终于响了。
It was a hockey friend of Duncan's who lived in Europe. He was trying to track Duncan down because he'd just spoken to the Dundee Tigers team manager. It looked like Duncan had never made it to Scotland. It was an anxiety-filled 24 hours for Linda and Bob McPherson until they finally made contact with Duncan's friend George Peshut the following day, Thursday August 17. George was a Canadian ice hockey player who had recently accepted a position on a German team and he was living in the German city of Nuremberg. He told the McPhersons that he and Duncan had spent a couple of days together before George had to
那是邓肯在欧洲的一位冰球朋友。他一直在寻找邓肯，因为他刚与邓迪老虎队的经理通过话。看起来邓肯根本没有到达苏格兰。对于琳达和鲍勃·麦克弗森来说，这是充满焦虑的 24 小时，直到第二天，即 8 月 17 日星期四，他们终于联系上了邓肯的朋友乔治·佩舒特。乔治是一名加拿大冰球运动员，最近接受了德国一支球队的职位，住在德国城市纽伦堡。他告诉麦克弗森夫妇，他和邓肯在一起待了几天，然后乔治不得不
go away for training camp on August 7. Duncan wanted to visit some friends and do some travelling, so George lent him his car, a red Opel Corsa. The plan was for Duncan to be back in Nuremberg by August 11 to return George's car and catch his flight to Scotland. But George said he'd just returned from his training camp. To his surprise, Duncan's hockey bag was still there, but Duncan and the Opal courser were not. After making a few more calls, the Macphersons discovered that on Monday August 7, Duncan had left Nuremberg and driven three hours north to the Bavarian town of Fussan. There, he stayed with his friend Roger, another Canadian ice hockey player who was living in Europe. It was a short but enjoyable visit. The two played tennis together and then
去参加 8 月 7 日的训练营。邓肯想去拜访一些朋友并四处旅行，所以乔治把他的车——一辆红色欧宝可赛（Opel Corsa）借给了他。计划是邓肯在 8 月 11 日前回到纽伦堡，归还乔治的车并搭乘飞往苏格兰的航班。但乔治说他刚从训练营回来。令他惊讶的是，邓肯的冰球包还在那里，但邓肯和欧宝可赛车都不见了。在打了几个电话后，麦克弗森夫妇发现，8 月 7 日星期一，邓肯离开了纽伦堡，向北驱车三小时前往巴伐利亚小镇富森（Fussen）。在那里，他与朋友罗杰（Roger）住在一起，罗杰是另一位住在欧洲的加拿大冰球运动员。那是一次短暂而愉快的访问。两人一起打了网球，然后
went out for dinner, where Roger got a kick out of Duncan's attempts to water without speaking a word of German. Duncan stayed at Roger's house that night, then hit the road again at around lunchtime the following day of Tuesday August 8. Roger told the McPhersons he wasn't entirely sure of Duncan's plans from there. Fussen is just one kilometre north of the Austrian border and only a few hours' drive from Italy. Duncan had mentioned wanting to visit a friend in the Italian city of Bolzano, but nothing was set in stone. He'd departed from Rogers with no specific plans, and neither Roger, George, nor any of Duncan's other contacts in Europe had heard from him since. Upon learning this information, Linda's heart sank.
出去吃晚饭，罗杰对邓肯在不会说德语的情况下尝试点餐感到很有趣。那天晚上邓肯住在罗杰家，第二天，即 8 月 8 日星期二午餐时间左右，他又踏上了旅程。罗杰告诉麦克弗森夫妇，他不完全确定邓肯接下来的计划。富森距离奥地利边境仅一公里，距离意大利也只有几小时车程。邓肯曾提到想去意大利城市博尔扎诺（Bolzano）拜访一位朋友，但并没有确定。他离开罗杰家时没有任何具体计划，从那以后，罗杰、乔治以及邓肯在欧洲的其他任何联系人都没再收到他的消息。得知这些信息后，琳达的心沉了下去。
She and her husband had raised Duncan and his brother to be reliable, respectful, and trustworthy young men. While Duncan was definitely keen for an adventure after years dedicated to hockey, he was a rule follower who adored his family. There was no way he would have just taken off and bailed on his job commitment without so much as a phone call. He also had a lot of respect for George Peshwood and would never run off with his car without seeking permission first. The Macphersons contacted their bank to find out when Duncan had last cashed one of his travellers' checks. They were told it was Monday,
她和丈夫将邓肯和他的兄弟培养成了可靠、尊重他人且值得信赖的年轻人。虽然邓肯在多年致力于冰球运动后确实渴望冒险，但他是一个遵守规则的人，非常爱他的家人。他绝不可能就这样不打一声招呼就离开并放弃他的工作承诺。他也非常尊重乔治·佩舒特，绝不会在未征得许可的情况下就开走他的车。麦克弗森夫妇联系了他们的银行，想查明邓肯最后一次兑现旅行支票的时间。他们被告知是周一，
August 7, the day Duncan visited Roger in Fusan. This meant that 10 days had passed without Duncan accessing any of his money. The Macpherson's anxiety spiked as they considered all possibilities. What if Duncan had accidentally driven George's car off the road and he was concealed in a ditch or mountainside somewhere? What if he'd picked up a hitchhiker who caused him harm? In the 1980s, kidnappings for ransom weren't unheard of in Italy. What if Duncan had unwittingly crossed paths with the mafia? After two more days passed with no word from Duncan, on Sunday August 20, the McPhersons contacted the Royal Canadian Mounted Police, or RCMP, and reported the 23-year-old to be missing.
8 月 7 日，也就是邓肯拜访富森罗杰的那天。这意味着邓肯在 10 天内没有动用过任何资金。麦克弗森夫妇在考虑所有可能性时，焦虑感急剧上升。如果邓肯不小心把乔治的车开出了路面，被困在某个沟渠或山坡上怎么办？如果他搭载了一个对他造成伤害的搭车客怎么办？在 20 世纪 80 年代，意大利并非没有发生过绑架勒索事件。如果邓肯无意中与黑手党发生了冲突怎么办？在又过了两天仍没有邓肯的消息后，8 月 20 日星期日，麦克弗森夫妇联系了加拿大皇家骑警（RCMP），报告这名 23 岁的年轻人失踪了。
or RCMP and reported the 23-year-old to be missing. To their surprise, their situation wasn't treated with any sense of urgency. Instead, they were told to call back again during regular office hours on Monday. When the McPherson's finally made contact with the police the next day, the officers they spoke to told them not to worry. Duncan was an adult who was free to do as he pleased. Like many other young foreigners, he'd likely just gotten caught up in an adventure or had met a girl and would resurface again soon. Or maybe he intended to disappear for a while, which as an adult he was free to do. The Macphersons didn't believe any of these reasons for a second. Not only would they have been completely out of character for Duncan, he also had a girlfriend back at home and the two had been making plans for her to come and visit him in Scotland.
或者加拿大皇家骑警，并报告这名 23 岁的年轻人失踪了。令他们惊讶的是，他们的情况并没有得到任何紧急处理。相反，他们被告知周一办公时间再打来。当麦克弗森夫妇第二天终于联系上警方时，他们交谈的警官告诉他们不要担心。邓肯是一个成年人，有自由做他想做的事。像许多其他年轻的外国人一样，他可能只是沉迷于冒险或遇到了一个女孩，很快就会重新出现。或者也许他打算消失一段时间，作为一个成年人，他有权这样做。麦克弗森夫妇一秒钟也不相信这些理由。这不仅完全不符合邓肯的性格，而且他在家里还有一个女朋友，两人一直在计划让她去苏格兰看望他。
When Duncan still hadn't contacted anyone by Wednesday August 23, the RCMP finally alerted Interpol and a bulletin was distributed to police stations and border crossings throughout Europe. While the Macphersons were relieved to know that Duncan was officially being treated as a missing person, the authorities continued to reassure them that he'd likely show up soon. Linda and Bob felt completely helpless waiting around in Saskatoon. They realised that the only way to ensure the search for their son was taken seriously was to fly to Europe and to do it themselves. On Sunday August 27, the couple touched down in Germany armed with 2,000 missing person posters printed in various languages. By now, Duncan had been missing for well over two weeks. Their first stop was to the missing persons unit of the Nuremberg police.
当 8 月 23 日星期三邓肯仍未联系任何人时，加拿大皇家骑警终于通知了国际刑警组织，一份公告被分发到欧洲各地的警察局和边境口岸。虽然麦克弗森夫妇得知邓肯已被正式列为失踪人员感到宽慰，但当局继续向他们保证，他很快就会出现。琳达和鲍勃在萨斯卡通等待时感到完全无助。他们意识到，要确保儿子失踪案受到重视，唯一的办法就是飞往欧洲，亲自去寻找。8 月 27 日星期日，这对夫妇抵达德国，随身携带了 2000 张用多种语言印制的失踪人员海报。此时，邓肯已经失踪两周多了。他们的第一站是纽伦堡警方的失踪人员部门。
Like the RCMP, the officer in charge assured the worried parents that Duncan was likely off chasing romance. At six foot one, he was a strong, athletic young man and he'd be able to take care of himself in the face of danger. Linda pointed out that 20 days had passed since he'd last cashed one of his travellers checks. Still, this raised no alarm bells for the police officer. He assured the McPhersons that the girl Duncan was with was probably rich. Frustrated that they weren't being taken seriously, Linda and Bob rented a car and began tracing Duncan's movements themselves. This was no easy feat for the middle-aged couple. They were modest people who enjoyed a quiet and wholesome life. Neither of them had ever been
像加拿大皇家骑警一样，负责的警官向这对焦虑的父母保证，邓肯很可能是在追求浪漫。他身高六英尺一英寸，是一个强壮、运动型的年轻人，在危险面前能够照顾好自己。琳达指出，距离他最后一次兑现旅行支票已经过去了 20 天。然而，这并没有引起警官的警觉。他向麦克弗森夫妇保证，和邓肯在一起的女孩可能很有钱。琳达和鲍勃对他们不被重视感到沮丧，于是租了一辆车，开始亲自追踪邓肯的行踪。对于这对中年夫妇来说，这绝非易事。他们是谦逊的人，享受着安静而健康的生活。他们两人以前从未
to Europe before and they didn't speak any of the local languages. Linda was a school teacher and Bob a small plane pilot. They'd won their home in a raffle which had afforded them a comfortable upbringing for their two boys. Venturing across Europe to take on the authorities was far beyond their comfort zone, but they both remained convinced that they'd find Duncan no matter what. Duncan had cashed his last travellers check at a travel agency in Nuremberg. The Macphersons went there and showed the staff a photo of their son. One of the agents recalled serving Duncan there on Monday August 7. He had put a deposit down for a flight to the Scottish city of Glasgow set to depart five days later on Saturday August 12. This was the same date he told his parents he would contact them
去过欧洲，也不会说任何当地语言。琳达是一名学校教师，鲍勃是一名小型飞机飞行员。他们通过抽奖赢得了自己的房子，这为他们的两个儿子提供了舒适的成长环境。冒险穿越欧洲去挑战当局远超出了他们的舒适区，但他们两人仍然坚信，无论如何都要找到邓肯。邓肯在纽伦堡的一家旅行社兑现了他最后一张旅行支票。麦克弗森夫妇去了那里，向工作人员展示了他们儿子的照片。其中一名代理人回忆起 8 月 7 日星期一曾接待过邓肯。他支付了一张飞往苏格兰城市格拉斯哥的机票定金，定于五天后的 8 月 12 日星期六出发。这正是他告诉父母他会联系他们的日期。
from Scotland. According to the travel agent, Duncan said he'd return to the office the day before the flight to pay the remaining balance and pick up his ticket, but he never did. From there, the McPherson's drove to Fussen, the German town where Duncan was last seen by his friend Roger. Studying a map, they tried to put themselves in Duncan's shoes. Given Fussen's proximity to both Austria and Italy, it made sense to assume he might have visited one of the nearby towns in either country. Austria offered world-class skiing while northern Italy offered windsurfing, both activities that would appeal to the outdoor sport-loving Duncan. He'd mentioned to Roger that he'd like to visit Italy's Lake Garda,
从苏格兰出发。据旅行社代理人称，邓肯说他会在航班起飞前一天回到办公室支付余款并领取机票，但他从未出现。从那里，麦克弗森夫妇开车前往富森，这是邓肯的朋友罗杰最后一次见到他的德国小镇。研究着地图，他们试图站在邓肯的角度思考。考虑到富森靠近奥地利和意大利，假设他可能访问过这两个国家附近的城镇是合理的。奥地利提供世界级的滑雪运动，而意大利北部则提供帆板运动，这两项活动都会吸引热爱户外运动的邓肯。他曾向罗杰提到想去意大利的加尔达湖（Lake Garda），
which was about a five-hour drive south of Fussen. Bob and Linda McPherson set out on this route, stopping at every regional police station along the way. For days they traversed all the areas they thought Duncan might have visited, plastering his missing person posters while on the constant lookout for George's red Opal Corsa. They checked with officials at the border crossings in Italy and Switzerland. Nobody they spoke to recalled seeing Duncan. In fact, to Bob and Linda's horror, none of the border officials or regional police were even aware of their son's case. In spite of what they'd been told by the RCMP, it didn't appear that an Interpol bulletin had been sent out. This meant that Duncan could have been passing through any number of towns and countries without anyone even being aware that missing person. Linda and Bob continued to go over every possible scenario in a desperate bid to
距离富森向南约五小时车程。鲍勃和琳达·麦克弗森踏上了这条路线，沿途在每个地区的警察局停留。几天来，他们走遍了他们认为邓肯可能去过的所有地方，张贴他的失踪人员海报，同时不断寻找乔治那辆红色的欧宝可赛车。他们向意大利和瑞士边境口岸的官员进行了核实。他们交谈过的任何人都没记得见过邓肯。事实上，令鲍勃和琳达感到震惊的是，边境官员或地区警察中竟然没有人知道他们儿子的案件。尽管加拿大皇家骑警告诉他们，但似乎并没有发出国际刑警组织的公告。这意味着邓肯可能经过了许多城镇和国家，而没有人知道他是失踪人员。琳达和鲍勃继续推敲每一个可能的方案，绝望地试图
figure out what could have happened to their son. Soon, another unnerving possibility began to enter their minds. A few months before Duncan had left for Europe, he'd fulfilled a dream of his by hiking North America's Appalachian Trail. While it had been a positive experience for the nature lover, he'd returned with an unwanted souvenir – Lyme disease. Transmitted by tick bites, Lyme disease is typically characterised by a rash, body aches, fever and fatigue. Duncan had fully recovered by the time he left for Europe, but after his disappearance, his parents learned that in rare cases, Lyme disease can leave individuals with memory loss, confusion and personality changes. They wondered whether Duncan could be
弄清楚他们的儿子可能发生了什么。很快，另一种令人不安的可能性开始进入他们的脑海。在邓肯前往欧洲的几个月前，他实现了徒步穿越北美阿巴拉契亚小径（Appalachian Trail）的梦想。虽然这对这位自然爱好者来说是一次积极的经历，但他带回了一个不受欢迎的纪念品——莱姆病。莱姆病通过蜱虫叮咬传播，通常表现为皮疹、身体疼痛、发烧和疲劳。邓肯在前往欧洲时已经完全康复，但在他失踪后，他的父母了解到，在极少数情况下，莱姆病会使人出现记忆丧失、困惑和性格改变。他们想知道邓肯是否可能
experiencing these symptoms. Maybe he was alive somewhere but suffering from some kind of neurological episode. There was also an odd comment that Duncan had made to his family in the months before his trip. Out of nowhere, he'd told Linda that a recruiter from the Central Intelligence Agency had tracked him down and asked if he'd be interested in working as a spy. This wasn't a far-fetched offer. Intelligent, athletic types like Duncan made attractive recruits. Linda had told Duncan it sounded like an exciting opportunity, but he said he wasn't interested. Working for the CIA would mean changing his identity and leaving his family behind, which he wasn't prepared to do. While it seemed unlikely, the McPhersons wondered whether Duncan had changed his mind
正在经历这些症状。也许他还活着，但在某个地方遭受某种神经系统发作的折磨。邓肯在旅行前几个月对家人发表过一个奇怪的评论。他突然告诉琳达，中央情报局（CIA）的一名招聘人员追踪到了他，并问他是否有兴趣担任间谍。这并不是一个牵强的提议。像邓肯这样聪明、运动型的人是很有吸引力的招募对象。琳达告诉邓肯这听起来是一个令人兴奋的机会，但他表示不感兴趣。为中央情报局工作意味着要改变身份并抛弃家人，他还没准备好这样做。虽然看起来不太可能，但麦克弗森夫妇想知道邓肯是否改变了主意，
and accepted a position with the agency after all. They also had a niggling feeling that something wasn't quite right about the job that Duncan had accepted with the Dundee Tigers in Scotland. He'd been offered the position by a Canadian businessman named Ron Dixon, who had recently bought the team. Ron offered Duncan the high-paying role, even though the two had never met. Duncan had been a little dubious. He told his family there was something off about Ron Dixon and his offer, but he'd pushed his concerns aside knowing it was too good an opportunity to turn down. Ron said that Duncan had called him at some point during his travels in Europe. He wasn't sure of the exact date, but he believed it was most likely on Thursday August 10.
最终接受了该机构的职位。他们还有一种隐隐的感觉，邓肯在苏格兰接受邓迪老虎队的工作有些不对劲。这份工作是由一位名叫罗恩·迪克森（Ron Dixon）的加拿大商人提供的，他最近买下了这支球队。罗恩向邓肯提供了这份高薪职位，尽管两人从未见过面。邓肯曾有些怀疑。他告诉家人，罗恩·迪克森和他的提议有些古怪，但他还是把担忧放在了一边，因为他知道这是一个不容错过的绝佳机会。罗恩说，邓肯在欧洲旅行期间曾给他打过电话。他不确定具体日期，但他认为很可能是在 8 月 10 日星期四。
This was two days after Duncan was last seen leaving Fussen and two days before his flight to Scotland. The Macphersons had no idea what to think. Every possibility was on the table, from foreign intelligence to amnesia to fair play. Yet, they were no closer to a breakthrough. Almost a month had passed with no reported sightings of Duncan. Then on Thursday September 14, Linda had an instinctive feeling that she knew where he was. When she and Bob had first driven from Fussan to Italy, their route had taken them through the Austrian city of Innsbruck. Known as the capital of the Alps, it was a charming city nestled amongst stunning mountain peaks that was known for offering a wide range of winter sports. Boasting impressive architecture, alpine views, and easy access to
这是邓肯最后一次被看到离开富森的两天后，也是他飞往苏格兰的两天前。麦克弗森夫妇不知道该想些什么。每一种可能性都在考虑范围内，从外国情报到失忆症，再到公平竞争。然而，他们离突破还很远。近一个月过去了，没有关于邓肯的目击报告。然后，在 9 月 14 日星期四，琳达有一种直觉，她知道他在哪里。当她和鲍勃第一次从富森开车到意大利时，他们的路线经过了奥地利城市因斯布鲁克（Innsbruck）。作为阿尔卑斯山的首府，它是一座迷人的城市，坐落在令人惊叹的山峰之中，以提供各种冬季运动而闻名。拥有令人印象深刻的建筑、高山景观和便捷的交通，
the ski slopes, it was exactly the kind of place that would have appealed to Duncan. It was also only a two hour drive from Fussen. Given that Duncan had just two days after leaving Roger before he was due back in Nuremberg, Linda reasoned that he wouldn't have wanted to waste too much of that time behind the wheel. It therefore made sense to her that Duncan would have decided to stop in Innsbruck for the night before seeing the sights the following day. Linda and Bob returned to Innsbruck and approached the local police, only to discover that they still hadn't been made aware of Duncan's disappearance. Linda expressed her belief that Duncan had likely stopped over in Innsbruck on the night
滑雪场，这正是会吸引邓肯的地方。它距离富森也只有两小时车程。考虑到邓肯在离开罗杰后还有两天时间才需要回到纽伦堡，琳达推断他不会想在开车上浪费太多时间。因此，对她来说，邓肯决定在因斯布鲁克过夜，第二天再去观光是有道理的。琳达和鲍勃回到因斯布鲁克并联系了当地警方，却发现他们仍然没有被告知邓肯失踪的消息。琳达表达了她的信念，即邓肯很可能在 8 月 8 日星期二晚上在因斯布鲁克停留过。
of Tuesday August 8. She requested that a search be done of all the hotels in the area to see if Duncan's name was any of their registers. The police refused. Innsbruck, which had twice hosted the Winter Olympics, had hundreds of hotels and guest lodgings. Making enquiries with each one would be a monumental task when they didn't even have any evidence to indicate Duncan had passed through the area. Like the others, Innsbruck
她要求对该地区的所有酒店进行搜查，看看邓肯的名字是否在他们的登记簿上。警方拒绝了。因斯布鲁克曾两次举办冬季奥运会，拥有数百家酒店和旅馆。在没有任何证据表明邓肯经过该地区的情况下，向每一家酒店进行询问将是一项艰巨的任务。像其他人一样，因斯布鲁克
police reassured the McPhersons that Duncan was likely off having an adventure and would show up soon. If he had come to Austria, his parents could rest assured that it was a safe country with a very low crime rate, and nothing bad would have happened to him. The Macphersons remained convinced that Duncan would have travelled to Winsbrook. They spent the next few days driving around town and the surrounding mountains, putting Duncan's missing person posters up and making inquiries of their own. Upon learning of their story, the head coach of the Innsbruck Hockey Club felt for the couple and pulled some strings to have Duncan's case broadcast on a local news network. The segment was broadcast on Wednesday September 20, almost 50 days since Duncan had vanished.
警方向麦克弗森夫妇保证，邓肯很可能是在外面冒险，很快就会出现。如果他真的来了奥地利，他的父母可以放心，这是一个犯罪率极低的国家，不会发生任何坏事。麦克弗森夫妇仍然坚信邓肯会去因斯布鲁克。接下来的几天，他们开车在城里和周围的山区转悠，张贴邓肯的失踪人员海报，并进行自己的调查。在得知他们的故事后，因斯布鲁克冰球俱乐部的主教练对这对夫妇深表同情，并动用关系让邓肯的案件在当地新闻网络上播出。该片段于 9 月 20 日星期三播出，距离邓肯失踪已经过去了近 50 天。
The Macphersons asked anyone who might have seen Duncan or his vehicle to come forward. Finally, someone did. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. With Robin Hood Gold, you don't need a silver spoon to weed up the financial favours of the 1%. Robin Hood Gold allows others to get the rates and perks usually reserved for the high society. Now, the resourceful individual with Robinhood Gold can earn the very liberal rate of 4.5% APY
麦克弗森夫妇请求任何可能见过邓肯或他的车辆的人站出来。终于，有人站出来了。Casefile 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。有了 Robinhood Gold，您不需要含着金汤匙出生也能获得 1% 的财务优惠。Robinhood Gold 让其他人能够获得通常只为上流社会保留的利率和福利。现在，拥有 Robinhood Gold 的足智多谋的个人可以赚取非常慷慨的 4.5% 年收益率（APY）
on uninvested cash and be rewarded with a handsome 3% retirement boost on an IRA account. Robinhood Gold provides the privileges of a high net worth for any net worth. These generous benefits are now available for only $5 per month. The new gold standard is here with Robinhood Gold. Sign up at robinhood.com slash gold. Terms apply. For product-specific disclosures, visit robinhood.com slash gold. Investing involves risk. Rate may change. Gold membership is offered by Robinhood Gold LLC. This episode of Case File is sponsored by BetterHelp. This month is all about gratitude, but there's one person we often overlook and forget to thank – ourselves. Remember,
在未投资的现金上，并因 IRA 账户获得 3% 的退休金奖励而获得回报。Robinhood Gold 为任何净资产的人提供高净值人士的特权。这些慷慨的福利现在每月仅需 5 美元即可获得。新的黄金标准随着 Robinhood Gold 到来。请在 robinhood.com/gold 注册。条款适用。有关产品特定披露，请访问 robinhood.com/gold。投资涉及风险。利率可能会发生变化。黄金会员资格由 Robinhood Gold LLC 提供。本集 Case File 由 BetterHelp 赞助。这个月的主题是感恩，但有一个人我们经常忽略并忘记感谢——我们自己。记住，
we're all doing our best in a challenging world. Take this as a reminder to show appreciation to those around you and don't forget yourself. The team at Casefile firmly believes in the benefits of therapy. It's not just for those who have experienced major trauma. Therapy can teach you coping skills, help you set boundaries, and provide a space to explore your thoughts and feelings without judgement. It can also help you recognise the progress you're making, no matter how small. If you've been thinking about starting therapy, consider giving BetterHelp a try. It's an online platform designed to be convenient, flexible, and tailored to your schedule. You simply fill out a brief questionnaire and BetterHelp will match you with a licensed therapist. Plus, if you feel the need to switch
我们都在这个充满挑战的世界中尽力而为。以此为提醒，向周围的人表达感激，也不要忘记自己。Casefile 团队坚信心理治疗的好处。它不仅仅适用于经历过重大创伤的人。治疗可以教你应对技巧，帮助你设定界限，并提供一个空间来探索你的想法和感受，而不受评判。它还可以帮助你认识到你正在取得的进步，无论多么微小。如果你一直在考虑开始心理治疗，请考虑尝试 BetterHelp。这是一个在线平台，旨在方便、灵活并根据你的时间表进行定制。你只需填写一份简短的问卷，BetterHelp 就会为你匹配一位持证治疗师。此外，如果你觉得需要更换
therapists, you can do so at any time with no extra cost. Let the gratitude flow with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash case file today to get 10 percent off your first month. That's betterhelp. 10% off your first month. That's better help. H-E-L-P dot com slash Casefile. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Sebastian Wagner, not his real name, was a contractor who had recently been doing some repair work to the parking lot of a popular ski resort known as the Stubai Glacier, 40 kilometres south of Innsbruck.
治疗师，你可以随时更换，无需额外费用。让感恩与 BetterHelp 一起流动。今天访问 betterhelp.com/casefile，首次购买可享受 10% 的折扣。那是 betterhelp。首次购买 10% 折扣。那是 better help。H-E-L-P 点 com 斜杠 Casefile。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 Casefile 继续提供高质量的内容。塞巴斯蒂安·瓦格纳（Sebastian Wagner，化名）是一名承包商，最近一直在为一个受欢迎的滑雪胜地——斯图拜冰川（Stubai Glacier）的停车场做一些维修工作，该胜地位于因斯布鲁克以南 40 公里处。
The Stubai Glacier is situated at the end of the Stubai Valley, roughly 3000 metres above sea level. It is made up of five glaciers, making it the largest glacier ski area in Austria. In the winter, hundreds of thousands of visitors from around the world flocked to the area to make the most of the snowfall. But it is just as popular in the summertime, with tourists drawn to the hiking trails, waterfalls, and alpine huts that dot the surrounding mountainside. When Sebastian saw the news bulletin about Duncan MacPherson's disappearance, he was certain he'd seen that red Opal Corsa before. It had been sitting in the parking lot of the Stubai Glacier Resort near the Gondola station for weeks. Sebastian immediately notified
斯图拜冰川位于斯图拜山谷的尽头，海拔约 3000 米。它由五条冰川组成，是奥地利最大的冰川滑雪区。冬天，来自世界各地的数十万游客涌向该地区，充分利用降雪。但它在夏天也同样受欢迎，游客们被周围山坡上的徒步小径、瀑布和高山小屋所吸引。当塞巴斯蒂安看到关于邓肯·麦克弗森失踪的新闻报道时，他确信自己以前见过那辆红色的欧宝可赛车。它已经在斯图拜冰川度假村靠近缆车站的停车场停了好几周了。塞巴斯蒂安立即通知了
the police, who followed up on the lead that night. The vehicle was right where Sebastian said it would be. At a quick glance, nothing appeared to be out of the ordinary. The driver's side window was slightly ajar, allowing the officers to reach inside and open it up. In the glove box, they found Duncan McPherson's passport and uncashed travellers' checks. A plastic bag of fruit sat rotting on the back seat, along with Duncan's backpack, a sweater, ice skates, and a hand-drawn map. Duncan himself was nowhere to be seen, nor were there any signs that a struggle had taken place. However, an unsent letter to his girlfriend provided a potential clue. In the letter, Duncan mentioned that he'd just bought a cool new pair of Mephisto brand
警方，他们当晚跟进了这条线索。车辆就在塞巴斯蒂安说的地方。粗略一看，似乎没有什么异常。驾驶座侧的车窗稍微开着，让警官可以伸手进去打开它。在手套箱里，他们发现了邓肯·麦克弗森的护照和未兑现的旅行支票。后座上放着一袋正在腐烂的水果，还有邓肯的背包、一件毛衣、溜冰鞋和一张手绘地图。邓肯本人不见踪影，也没有任何迹象表明发生过挣扎。然而，一封写给女朋友但未寄出的信提供了一个潜在的线索。在信中，邓肯提到他刚买了一双很酷的 Mephisto 品牌
walking shoes. The shoes weren't in Duncan's car, which raised the possibility that he might have warned them to go hiking on one of the nearby trails. Police immediately made inquiries with the accommodation providers in the area. Duncan McPherson hadn't been registered as a guest at any of the major hotels or the small Alpine huts, nor did anyone recognise him from his photograph. Bob and Linda MacPherson arrived at the Stubai Glacier the day after Duncan's car was found. Upon learning that the vehicle had been in the area for weeks, they were stunned. The Stubai Glacier is a major tourist attraction, bringing in millions of dollars in revenue each year. Every day, thousands of visitors and locals
步行鞋。鞋子不在邓肯的车里，这增加了他可能穿着它们去附近小径徒步旅行的可能性。警方立即向该地区的住宿提供商进行了询问。邓肯·麦克弗森没有在任何主要酒店或小型高山小屋登记入住，也没有人从照片中认出他。鲍勃和琳达·麦克弗森在邓肯的车被发现后的第二天抵达了斯图拜冰川。得知这辆车已经在该地区停放了数周，他们感到震惊。斯图拜冰川是一个主要的旅游景点，每年带来数百万美元的收入。每天，成千上万的游客和当地人
used the parking lot, but the glaciers shut for business in the evenings and the parking lot was virtually empty by 6pm. The Macphersons wondered how Duncan's car could have sat there for weeks without it raising any alarms, especially when police were aware that a tourist had gone missing in the area. The Macphersons checked into the nearby hotel to join the search for their son. As they were registering, a man approached them. He introduced himself as Walter Hinterhölzel, a Stubai Glacier snowboard instructor who also worked at the hotel part-time. Walter said he'd just seen the missing person poster taped to the window of the McPherson's rental car and recognised Duncan's photo. While most of the ski runs on the Stubai Glacier were
使用停车场，但冰川在晚上停止营业，停车场在下午 6 点后几乎空无一人。麦克弗森夫妇想知道邓肯的车怎么能在那里停放数周而没有引起任何警报，特别是在警方知道一名游客在该地区失踪的情况下。麦克弗森夫妇入住附近的酒店，加入寻找儿子的行列。当他们登记时，一名男子走近他们。他自我介绍说叫沃尔特·欣特霍尔泽尔（Walter Hinterhölzel），是一名斯图拜冰川单板滑雪教练，也在酒店兼职。沃尔特说他刚看到贴在麦克弗森租车窗户上的失踪人员海报，认出了邓肯的照片。虽然斯图拜冰川上的大多数滑雪道在
closed in August due to lack of snow, one small bunny hill with a rope tow lift remained open, known as the Schaufelfaner. Walter Hinterhölzel claimed that on the morning of Tuesday August 9, he had given Duncan a two-hour snowboarding lesson on the Schaufelfaner. He'd been impressed by how quickly Duncan had gotten the hang of things and how well he was able to control the board. After the lesson, the two ate lunch together. Duncan told Walter about his upcoming coaching job in Scotland and his desire to go windsurfing on Lake Garda before then. Walter recommended that Duncan visit Austria's Lake Aachen instead. It was less than an hour from Innsbruck and would give Duncan more time before he had to be back
8 月因缺乏积雪而关闭，但一条带有绳索牵引升降机的小型初学者坡道仍然开放，被称为 Schaufelfaner。沃尔特·欣特霍尔泽尔声称，在 8 月 9 日星期二早上，他在 Schaufelfaner 上给了邓肯一节两小时的单板滑雪课。邓肯掌握事物的速度以及他控制滑板的能力给他留下了深刻印象。课后，两人一起吃了午餐。邓肯告诉沃尔特他即将在苏格兰担任教练的工作，以及在此之前想去加尔达湖进行帆板运动的愿望。沃尔特建议邓肯去奥地利的亚琛湖（Lake Aachen）。它距离因斯布鲁克不到一小时路程，会让邓肯在必须回到
in Germany for his flight. Duncan seemed pleased by this. He told Walter he was going to spend the rest of the afternoon testing out his new snowboarding skills and might then go for a hike on one of the surrounding trails. He arranged to meet Walter again for a follow-up lesson the next morning. The jumper Duncan had been wearing was soaked through, so he bought a new one from the gift shop and hung his wet one out to dry in Walter's office before hitting the slope on his own. At the end of the day, Walter returned to his office only to find that Duncan's jumper was still there. He reasoned that Duncan would probably just pick it up after his lesson the next morning, but he never showed up, and the jumper remained unclaimed.
德国搭乘航班之前有更多时间。邓肯对此似乎很高兴。他告诉沃尔特，他打算花下午剩下的时间测试他新学的单板滑雪技巧，然后可能会去周围的小径徒步旅行。他安排第二天早上再和沃尔特见面进行后续课程。邓肯穿的套头衫被汗水浸透了，所以他从礼品店买了一件新的，并把湿的那件挂在沃尔特的办公室里晾干，然后独自去滑雪了。一天结束时，沃尔特回到办公室，发现邓肯的套头衫还在那里。他推断邓肯可能第二天早上上完课后会来取，但他从未出现，那件套头衫也一直无人认领。
The Shuffle Fairness ski run was located 3770 vertical feet above the parking lot. The only way to reach it was to ride the gondola or hike it on foot. only way to reach it was to ride the gondola or hike it on foot. The Macphersons rode the gondola up to see the slope for themselves. It was only a small area, its entire surface visible from the base. The ski run was clearly marked, with a rope cordon marking an out-of-bounds area to the east. The Macphersons knew there was no way something bad could have happened to Duncan at this spot. Not only was the slope smoothed over at the end of each day by a snow groomer machine, if Duncan had accidentally gone off course he would have left behind an obvious trail. He was also last seen wearing a bright yellow ski jacket which would have been
Shuffle Fairness 滑雪道位于停车场上方 3770 英尺处。到达那里的唯一方法是乘坐缆车或步行。麦克弗森夫妇乘坐缆车上去亲自查看坡道。那只是一个小区域，整个表面从底部清晰可见。滑雪道有明显的标记，东侧有一条绳索警戒线标出禁区。麦克弗森夫妇知道邓肯不可能在这个地方发生什么坏事。不仅坡道每天结束时都会由压雪机平整，如果邓肯不小心偏离了路线，他会留下明显的痕迹。他最后一次被看到时穿着一件亮黄色的滑雪夹克，这会非常
very visible. A search team combed the slope but didn't find any trace of Duncan. Walter Hinterhölzel's girlfriend, who was also employed by the Stubai Glacier, recalled seeing Duncan on the tow lift at 2.30pm on Wednesday August 9, shortly after he'd finished his lunch with Walter. This was the last confirmed sighting. Based on Duncan's conversation with Walter, police deduced that after practising snowboarding for a while, Duncan likely sat out on one of the hiking trails. This would explain why his new shoes were missing. Walter had advised Duncan to avoid hiking downhill because it would cause stress on his knees, which were weak from hockey injuries. One Stubai Glacier employee recalled seeing a tall young man standing near a waterfall below the glacier on August 9. In the
显眼。搜救队梳理了坡道，但没有发现邓肯的任何踪迹。沃尔特·欣特霍尔泽尔的女朋友，也是斯图拜冰川的员工，回忆起 8 月 9 日星期三下午 2 点 30 分在牵引升降机上看到邓肯，就在他与沃尔特吃完午餐后不久。这是最后一次确认的目击。根据邓肯与沃尔特的谈话，警方推断，在练习了一段时间单板滑雪后，邓肯可能去徒步旅行了。这可以解释为什么他的新鞋不见了。沃尔特曾建议邓肯避免下坡徒步，因为这会给他的膝盖带来压力，他的膝盖因冰球受伤而虚弱。一名斯图拜冰川员工回忆起 8 月 9 日看到一名高个子年轻男子站在冰川下方的一个瀑布附近。在
summer, the melting ice created deep well pools around the waterfall. Police theorised that Duncan could have ignored Walter's advice, hiking downhill to the waterfall where he fell in and drowned. They searched the falls but found nothing to indicate Duncan had been there. They focused their search further up the mountain instead, where snow continued to fall. There was no sign of Duncan there either. By Monday September 25, the search for Duncan MacPherson at the Stubai Glacier reached its fifth fruitless day. With no confirmed sightings of him after August 9, the police concluded that he'd likely gotten lost or had an accident on the mountain, and his body was concealed by snow. His abandoned car hadn't raised any alarms because hikers often left their vehicles in the
夏天，融化的冰在瀑布周围形成了深水潭。警方推断邓肯可能忽略了沃尔特的建议，下坡徒步到瀑布，在那里跌入水中溺亡。他们搜查了瀑布，但没有发现任何迹象表明邓肯去过那里。他们转而将搜寻重点放在山上更高的地方，那里积雪持续落下。那里也没有邓肯的踪迹。到 9 月 25 日星期一，在斯图拜冰川寻找邓肯·麦克弗森的行动进入了第五天，毫无收获。在 8 月 9 日之后没有确认目击他的情况下，警方得出结论，他很可能在山上迷路或发生了事故，尸体被积雪掩盖了。他被遗弃的汽车没有引起警报，因为徒步旅行者经常将车辆留在
Stubai Glacier parking lot while heading out for extended hiking trips, during which they camped at the Alpine huts along the way. Police reasoned that they hadn't patrolled the parking lot because it was private property. They called off the search, confident that Duncan's body would eventually be recovered by hikers or hunters in due course. Bob and Linda MacPherson were outraged by this conclusion. Without Duncan's body, how could the police be sure that he was even dead, let alone that he'd died by accident on the mountain somewhere? As far as his parents were concerned, Duncan could be anywhere. He might not even be dead.
斯图拜冰川停车场，同时前往进行长途徒步旅行，期间他们住在沿途的高山小屋里。警方推断他们没有巡逻停车场，因为那是私人财产。他们取消了搜寻，确信邓肯的尸体最终会在适当的时候被徒步旅行者或猎人发现。鲍勃和琳达·麦克弗森对这一结论感到愤怒。没有邓肯的尸体，警方怎么能确定他已经死了，更不用说他是死于山上的意外了？在父母看来，邓肯可能在任何地方。他甚至可能根本没有死。
Disappointed with the Innsbruck police investigation, the Macphersons were dubious about their claims that they'd found no record of Duncan having stayed anywhere in Innsbruck throughout August. Bob and Linda conducted their own inquiries and discovered that Duncan had indeed spent the night of Tuesday August 8 in a youth hostel downtown before checking out the next morning. While this bolstered the police theory that Duncan had disappeared on the same day he was last seen, the McPhersons couldn't help but wonder. If the police had overlooked a simple detail like Duncan's hostel registration, what else had they missed?
麦克弗森夫妇对因斯布鲁克警方的调查感到失望，他们怀疑警方声称在八月份没有邓肯在因斯布鲁克任何地方住宿记录的说法。鲍勃和琳达进行了自己的调查，发现邓肯确实在8月8日星期二晚上住在市中心的一家青年旅舍，第二天早上才退房。虽然这支持了警方关于邓肯是在最后一次露面当天失踪的理论，但麦克弗森夫妇不禁怀疑，如果警方连邓肯的旅舍登记这样简单的细节都忽略了，他们还错过了什么？
Ron Dixon, the owner of the Dundee Tigers ice hockey team, was confident he'd spoken to Duncan on Thursday August 10, the day after he'd been snowboarding at the Stubai Glacier. A recently purchased cassette tape found in Duncan's car was traced to a music store in Innsbruck where an employee remembered serving Duncan. She couldn't be sure exactly when, but she remembered one distinct detail. Duncan hadn't been alone, but with a dark-haired man. While it pained Bob and Linda to imagine, they considered whether Duncan might have been abducted and was being held captive. What if he was out there somewhere, willing his parents to find him?
邓迪老虎冰球队的老板罗恩·迪克森确信他在8月10日星期四，也就是邓肯在斯图拜冰川滑雪后的第二天与他交谈过。在邓肯的车里发现的一盘新买的磁带被追溯到因斯布鲁克的一家音乐商店，店里的一名员工记得曾接待过邓肯。她无法确定具体时间，但记得一个明显的细节：邓肯不是一个人，而是和一个黑发男子在一起。虽然想象这些让鲍勃和琳达感到痛苦，但他们考虑邓肯是否可能被绑架并被囚禁。如果他还活着，在某个地方渴望着父母找到他呢？
As Bob later told Esquire magazine, Even though we knew in our hearts that he probably wasn't alive, you always think there's some chance. That's what made us want to keep going. It's amazing how much you hang on to that thread. The tiniest bit of hope. They stewed over it for days before the realisation dawned on Linda. Walter Hinterhölzel, the snowboard instructor, had told the McPhersons that Duncan had rented a snowboard, gloves and ski boots prior to their lesson together. At the time, there was only one ski shop on the mountain. In order to rent any equipment, customers had to put a government
正如鲍勃后来告诉《时尚先生》杂志的那样：“尽管我们心里知道他可能已经不在人世了，但你总会觉得还有一线希望。这就是让我们坚持下去的原因。你能紧紧抓住那一线希望，这真是太神奇了。哪怕是最微小的一点希望。”在琳达意识到这一点之前，他们为此苦恼了几天。滑雪教练沃尔特·辛特霍尔泽曾告诉麦克弗森夫妇，邓肯在他们一起上课前租了一块滑雪板、手套和滑雪靴。当时，山上只有一家滑雪店。为了租用任何设备，顾客必须提供政府
issued ID or credit card down as a deposit, which would be returned to them when handing over their gear at the end of the day. It occurred to Linda that staff at the shop would be able to tell them whether or not Duncan returned his gear. If he hadn't, this would signify that he might have had an accident while he was out snowboarding, instead of after. Linda visited the rental shop and asked them to check their records. The staff told her they'd recently started a new log and had therefore thrown the old one away. While none of the employees specifically recalled Duncan returning his gear. No snowboards were missing from their inventory, so they reasoned that he must have returned it.
签发的身份证或信用卡作为押金，并在一天结束时交还装备时退还。琳达想到店里的工作人员应该能告诉他们邓肯是否归还了装备。如果他没有归还，这就意味着他可能是在滑雪时发生了事故，而不是在滑雪之后。琳达去了租赁店，请他们核对记录。工作人员告诉她，他们最近刚开始使用新的日志，所以把旧的扔掉了。虽然没有员工特别记得邓肯归还了装备，但他们的库存中没有丢失滑雪板，所以他们推断他一定归还了。
It was protocol for staff to inform guards of any rental equipment that hadn't been returned so they could check the slope for any potential accidents. If the police theory was correct and Duncan really had perished while hiking in the Stubai Valley, his parents couldn't bear the thought of his body being left out there all alone. With winter just around the corner, they knew that time was of the essence, as any search efforts would be hindered completely once the heavy snowfall began. be hindered completely once the heavy snowfall began. A Canadian businessman heard about the situation and generously funded a Canadian search and rescue team to fly to Austria and continue the search themselves. They arrived on Sunday October 8, the beginning of the third month of Duncan's
工作人员有义务将任何未归还的租赁设备通知警卫，以便他们检查斜坡是否有潜在事故。如果警方的理论是正确的，邓肯确实是在斯图拜山谷徒步旅行时遇难的，那么他的父母无法忍受他的尸体被独自留在那里。随着冬天的临近，他们知道时间紧迫，因为一旦大雪开始，任何搜救工作都将完全受阻。一位加拿大商人听说了这种情况，慷慨资助了一支加拿大搜救队飞往奥地利，继续自行搜寻。他们于10月8日星期日抵达，那是邓肯失踪的第三个月的开始。
disappearance. With the help of some new computer software and a sniffer dog, they started from the Stubai Glacier Resort parking lot and searched outwards around the valley from there. The days ticked by with no breakthroughs, and by Sunday October 15, the team was forced to call off the search on account of heavy snowfall. Defeated, Bob and Linda MacPherson felt there was nothing more they could do. They reluctantly returned to Canada, vowing to come back as soon as the snow melted. Around at the same time that the Macphersons left Austria, the manager of one of the Alpine huts in the Stubai Valley came across one of Duncan's missing posters for the first time. Upon seeing Duncan's face, he was reminded of a strange incident that had occurred a couple of
在一些新计算机软件和搜救犬的帮助下，他们从斯图拜冰川度假村的停车场出发，向山谷周围进行搜寻。日子一天天过去，没有任何突破。到了10月15日星期日，由于大雪纷飞，搜救队被迫取消了搜寻。鲍勃和琳达·麦克弗森感到无能为力，别无他法。他们不情愿地回到了加拿大，发誓一旦雪融化就回来。就在麦克弗森夫妇离开奥地利的同时，斯图拜山谷一家高山小屋的经理第一次看到了邓肯的寻人启事。看到邓肯的脸，他想起了一个奇怪的事件，发生在几
weeks earlier. On Monday September 25, a dishevelled looking English-speaking foreigner had shown up at the hut in the middle of the night. He'd trekked there through the dark without suitable hiking gear, not even a flashlight. He seemed a little disoriented and had taken off again after breakfast the next morning, heading towards the old smugglers' trails into Italy. The hut manager thought the man bore a resemblance to Duncan McPherson. Bob and Linda weren't sure what to make of this. The police had assured them that all the hut managers had been notified of Duncan's disappearance, so it seemed odd that such an encounter could have occurred without it raising suspicions at the time. Then again, it gave
周前。9月25日星期一，一个衣衫褴褛、说英语的外国人半夜出现在小屋。他没有合适的徒步装备，甚至没有手电筒，就在黑暗中跋涉到了那里。他看起来有点迷失方向，第二天早上吃完早餐后又出发了，朝着通往意大利的旧走私小径走去。小屋经理认为这个人长得像邓肯·麦克弗森。鲍勃和琳达不知道该怎么想。警方曾向他们保证，所有小屋经理都已收到邓肯失踪的通知，所以这样的相遇竟然没有引起当时的怀疑，这似乎很奇怪。话又说回来，这给了
them hope that Duncan could be experiencing amnesia as a result of his Lyme disease or an accident, and could still be alive after all. As the months passed by, other potential sightings of Duncan continued to trickle in. One Canadian tourist thought she spotted him at a bar in Russia. Thinking fast, she took a photo and sent it to his family. But it wasn't Duncan. The McPhersons couldn't shake the feeling that Ron Dixon, the man who'd offered Duncan the coaching job, knew more about Duncan's disappearance than he was letting on. Not only did Ron claim to be one of the last people to speak with Duncan before he went missing, the Macphersons found it odd that he hadn't contacted them to let them know Duncan
他们希望，邓肯可能因为莱姆病或事故而患上健忘症，毕竟他还活着。随着时间的推移，其他关于邓肯的潜在目击报告不断传来。一位加拿大游客以为她在俄罗斯的一家酒吧里看到了他。她反应很快，拍了一张照片发给了他的家人。但那不是邓肯。麦克弗森夫妇无法摆脱一种感觉，即那个向邓肯提供教练工作的罗恩·迪克森，对邓肯的失踪知道的比他透露的要多。罗恩不仅声称是邓肯失踪前最后与他交谈的人之一，麦克弗森夫妇还觉得奇怪的是，他没有联系他们告知邓肯
never arrived in Scotland. He'd never even reached out to offer any support. The Macphersons did some digging and discovered that Ron Dixon had a shady past. Rumours swirled about his dodgy real estate ventures and a criminal record that included a prison sentence for manslaughter. The Macphersons wondered if Duncan's job offer seemed too good to be true because something more sinister had been at play. Regardless, they weren't discounting the possibility that Duncan had indeed died by accident around the Stubai glacier. In the summer of 1990,
从未抵达苏格兰。他甚至从未主动提供任何支持。麦克弗森夫妇进行了一些挖掘，发现罗恩·迪克森有着阴暗的过去。关于他可疑的房地产投资和包括过失杀人罪在内的犯罪记录的传言四起。麦克弗森夫妇怀疑邓肯的工作机会是否好得令人难以置信，因为背后有更险恶的事情。无论如何，他们并没有排除邓肯确实在斯图拜冰川附近意外死亡的可能性。1990年夏天，
they returned to Austria, bringing Duncan's beloved dog Jake with them. For weeks, they camped in the Stubai valley and hiked the surrounding trails on the lookout for any sign of Duncan. They returned every summer for the next three years, but came no closer to finding him. In late 1993, a German television program called Bittermeldedick aired a segment about Duncan's disappearance, urging anyone with information about his whereabouts to come forward. A woman named Lena, not her real name, was watching the show when something occurred to her. Lena lived in the Austrian city of Klagenfurt, roughly 320 kilometres southeast of Innsbruck. Four years earlier, on Saturday September 9, 1989, a distressed and malnourished young man had emerged from the woods in a town about half an hour from Clarkenfort.
他们回到了奥地利，带着邓肯心爱的狗杰克。几个星期以来，他们露营在斯图拜山谷，徒步走遍了周围的小径，寻找邓肯的任何踪迹。接下来的三年里，他们每年夏天都回来，但离找到他并没有更近一步。1993年底，一个名为《Bittermeldedick》的德国电视节目播出了关于邓肯失踪的片段，敦促任何有他下落信息的人站出来。一个名叫莉娜（化名）的女人在看节目时，突然想到了什么。莉娜住在奥地利的克拉根福市，距离因斯布鲁克东南约320公里。四年前，即1989年9月9日星期六，一个痛苦且营养不良的年轻人从克拉根福附近一个小镇的树林里走了出来。
Speaking only North American English, he had no identification on him and claimed he couldn't remember his name, where he came from, or anything else about his life. The only thing he could remember was that he'd once lived in New York. The mystery man was arrested for vagrancy before being transferred to a mental health facility. Doctors initially thought he might be suffering from some type of neurological condition, but when he didn't respond to any of the treatments, it was determined that he had a severe case of amnesia. The man was given the green light to live in Austria. He settled in Klagenfurt where he went by the name Mark Scherfman. Over time, Lena became friends with Mark. Other than the fact that he couldn't remember his true
他只会说北美英语，身上没有任何证件，声称不记得自己的名字、来自哪里，或者关于他生活的任何其他事情。他唯一能记得的是他曾经住在纽约。这个神秘男子因流浪罪被捕，随后被转移到一家心理健康机构。医生最初认为他可能患有某种神经系统疾病，但当他对任何治疗都没有反应时，确定他患有严重的健忘症。该男子获准在奥地利居住。他在克拉根福定居，化名马克·谢尔夫曼。随着时间的推移，莉娜和马克成了朋友。除了他不记得自己的真实
identity, there was nothing unusual about him. He was a nice guy who lived an otherwise normal life. But when Lena saw the bitter Meldediek segment about Duncan McPherson's disappearance, it gave her pause. Mark Scherfman had emerged from the woods exactly one month after Duncan McPherson was last seen at the Stubai Glacier, only a few hundred kilometres away. Mark had been wearing an American brand of jeans, just like Duncan had. Duncan had had various surgeries on his knees. Mark's knees also had surgical scars on them. Duncan's front teeth had been knocked out during a hockey match and had been replaced with crowns. Mark's front teeth had received similar dental work. Looking at Duncan's picture on the television, Lena saw the similarities and wondered, could
身份外，他没有什么不寻常之处。他是一个好人，过着正常的生活。但当莉娜看到关于邓肯·麦克弗森失踪的《Bittermeldedick》片段时，她停顿了一下。马克·谢尔夫曼从树林里走出来的时间，正好是邓肯·麦克弗森最后一次在斯图拜冰川露面一个月后，而且距离只有几百公里。马克穿着美国品牌的牛仔裤，就像邓肯一样。邓肯的膝盖做过各种手术。马克的膝盖上也有手术疤痕。邓肯的前牙在冰球比赛中被打掉，并换成了牙冠。马克的前牙也接受了类似的牙科治疗。看着电视上邓肯的照片，莉娜看到了相似之处，心想，这两个人
the two men be one and the same? Lena shared her suspicions with her boyfriend, who managed to get a hold of the McPherson's phone number. In early February 1994, he called them in Canada to pass on the information. Bob and Linda didn't know what to think. Given Duncan's brush with Lyme disease just before his trip to Europe, the possibility that he was experiencing amnesia seemed entirely plausible. And what were the chances that two young North American men could
会不会是同一个人？莉娜把她的怀疑告诉了她的男朋友，他设法弄到了麦克弗森家的电话号码。1994年2月初，他打电话给在加拿大的他们，转达了这一信息。鲍勃和琳达不知道该怎么想。考虑到邓肯在去欧洲旅行前刚患过莱姆病，他患上健忘症的可能性似乎完全合理。而且，两个年轻的北美男子在短短几周内
go missing within such close proximity within just a few weeks of one another? The Macphersons contacted Foreign Affairs, who arranged to have someone from the Canadian Embassy in Austria visit Mark Scherfman. Everything Lena said was true. Mark and Duncan did share many similarities. The Embassy officials even took Mark to an ice skating rink to put his skills to the test. It turned out he was a talented skater. A picture of Mark was faxed to the Macphersons in Canada. They gathered around the fax machine along with some of Duncan's friends, anticipation soaring as the image emerged. But Mark Scherfman looked nothing like Duncan.
在如此近的距离内失踪的可能性有多大？麦克弗森夫妇联系了外交部，安排加拿大驻奥地利大使馆的人员去探望马克·谢尔夫曼。莉娜所说的一切都是真的。马克和邓肯确实有很多相似之处。大使馆官员甚至带马克去溜冰场测试他的技能。事实证明，他是一个有天赋的滑冰运动员。马克的照片被传真给了在加拿大的麦克弗森夫妇。他们和邓肯的一些朋友围在传真机旁，随着图像的出现，期待感高涨。但马克·谢尔夫曼看起来一点也不像邓肯。
His loved ones considered every conceivable possibility that Duncan's appearance could have changed in the four years since his disappearance, and embassy officials ordered a comparison of the two men's dental records. They didn't match. A former teammate of Duncan's who was living in Austria went to visit Mark just in case. But to the crushing disappointment of many, he confirmed that Mark Scherfman and Duncan McPherson were definitely not the same person. In the summers that followed, Bob and Linda spent their life savings returning to Austria. They refused to change their phone number or move
他的亲人们考虑了邓肯在失踪后的四年里外貌可能发生变化的每一种可能性，大使馆官员下令对两人的牙科记录进行比对。它们不匹配。一位住在奥地利的邓肯的前队友去拜访了马克，以防万一。但令许多人感到极度失望的是，他证实马克·谢尔夫曼和邓肯·麦克弗森绝对不是同一个人。在随后的夏天，鲍勃和琳达花光了他们的积蓄回到奥地利。他们拒绝更改电话号码或搬
house just in case Duncan ever tried to get in touch. By 2003, Duncan had been missing for 14 years. Bob and Linda could no longer afford the annual trips, and they did their best to get on with their lives, even though their sun was never far from their minds. That summer, the temperature soared to record heights in Innsbruck. So much of the winter snow melted that even the Schaufelferner ski run had to be closed down. On Friday July 18 2003, a Stubai Glacier employee was walking along the empty ski run collecting rubbish when they noticed something sticking out of the snow approximately 35 metres east of the ski lift. At the McPherson's home in Saskatoon, the phone rang the next day. It was a friend of theirs from Innsbruck. They found Duncan, he said.
家，以防邓肯试图联系他们。到2003年，邓肯已经失踪了14年。鲍勃和琳达再也负担不起每年的旅行，他们尽力继续生活，尽管他们的儿子从未远离他们的脑海。那年夏天，因斯布鲁克的温度飙升至创纪录的高度。冬天的积雪融化得如此之多，以至于连Schaufelferner滑雪道也不得不关闭。2003年7月18日星期五，一名斯图拜冰川的员工沿着空荡荡的滑雪道走着收集垃圾时，注意到滑雪缆车以东约35米处的雪地里有什么东西露了出来。第二天，在萨斯卡通的麦克弗森家中，电话响了。是他们在因斯布鲁克的一位朋友。他说，他们找到了邓肯。
Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. We all dread the what's for dinner question. I know I do. Ordering takeout is often the default option but it's hardly satisfying and you'll always end up spending more. If you'd rather enjoy a home cooked meal without the stress of planning ahead, Home Chef makes it simple and helps save you money. Home Chef brings fresh ingredients and easy chef designed recipes straight to your door. Whether you want classic meal kits with pre-portioned ingredients, 30 minute recipes or quick microwave meals, Home Chef makes it simple to enjoy tasty, stress-free meals
Casefile节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。我们都害怕“晚餐吃什么”这个问题。我知道我怕。点外卖通常是默认选择，但这很难让人满意，而且你最终总是会花更多的钱。如果您想在没有提前计划压力的情况下享受家常菜，Home Chef让一切变得简单，并帮助您省钱。Home Chef将新鲜食材和简单的厨师设计食谱直接送到您家门口。无论您是想要带有预先分好份量食材的经典餐包、30分钟食谱还是快速微波炉餐，Home Chef都能让您轻松享受美味、无压力的餐点
for the whole family. Home Chef offers over 30 meal choices each week and caters to many dietary needs. They even have a tasty, kid-friendly menu that's perfect for picky eaters, making dinner time stress-free. Besides being convenient, Home Chef is also budget-friendly. Customers save an average of $86 a month on groceries. Olivia LaVoice, host of Casefile Presents series The Bakersfield 3, is loving Home Chef for its convenience and the high quality of ingredients supplied. She says it's also introduced her to new recipes she wouldn't have otherwise made.
为全家人提供服务。Home Chef每周提供超过30种餐点选择，并满足许多饮食需求。他们甚至有美味、适合儿童的菜单，非常适合挑食者，让晚餐时间变得无压力。除了方便之外，Home Chef还很经济实惠。顾客每月在杂货上平均节省86美元。Casefile Presents系列《The Bakersfield 3》的主持人奥利维亚·拉沃伊斯（Olivia LaVoice）非常喜欢Home Chef的便利性和所提供食材的高品质。她说，它还向她介绍了她原本不会制作的新食谱。
She says it's also introduced her to new recipes she wouldn't have otherwise made. For a limited time, Home Chef is offering my listeners 18 free meals plus free dessert for life and of course free shipping on your first box. Go to homechef.com slash case file. That's homeshef.com slash case file for 18 free meals and free dessert for life. You heard that right. Homeshef.com slash case file. Did you know 66% of utility damage is caused by not requesting a locate? Don't let your project become part of this statistic. A quick locate request can save you from unexpected downtime, financial penalties, and keep you safe. Don't let avoidable damage cost you time and money.
她说，它还向她介绍了她原本不会制作的新食谱。在有限的时间内，Home Chef为我的听众提供18顿免费餐点，外加终身免费甜点，当然还有首个包裹免费送货。请访问homechef.com斜杠casefile。即homeshef.com斜杠casefile，可获得18顿免费餐点和终身免费甜点。你没听错。Homeshef.com斜杠casefile。你知道吗，66%的公用设施损坏是由于未请求定位造成的？不要让你的项目成为这个统计数据的一部分。快速的定位请求可以让你免于意外停机、经济处罚，并确保你的安全。不要让可避免的损坏浪费你的时间和金钱。
Click before you dig. Ensure your next project is safe. Visit OntarioOneCall.ca. It's free. It's easy, it's the law. Data sourced from the ORCGA 2023 DIRT Report. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. It didn't take long for the Innsbruck police to confirm that Duncan had died by accident on the same day he was last seen back on Wednesday August 9 1989. His body had been buried in a small crevasse and was seemingly frozen in time. Dressed in the same bright yellow ski jacket and the newly purchased jumper he'd been wearing at
挖掘前请点击。确保你的下一个项目是安全的。访问OntarioOneCall.ca。它是免费的，很容易，而且是法律规定的。数据来源于ORCGA 2023 DIRT报告。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。因斯布鲁克警方很快证实，邓肯在1989年8月9日星期三最后一次露面的当天就意外死亡了。他的尸体被埋在一个小裂缝中，似乎被冻结在时间里。他穿着失踪时穿着的同一件亮黄色滑雪夹克和新买的套头衫，
the time of his disappearance, his pockets still held his wallet which contained essentials for his European trip, including his international driver's license and a Canadian calling card. The snowboard and ski boots he'd supposedly returned to the rental shop were also still with him. Similar crevasses to the one Duncan's body was found in crisscrossed all over the Stubai Glacier. found in crisscrossed all over the Stubai glacier. To make the area safe for skiers, piston bullies groomed the ski runs at the end of each day, filling each of the crevasses in with snow. Ungroomed areas were cordoned off to make sure skiers didn't veer out of bounds. The ski lift operator insisted that the area to the left and right of the ski lift had been cordoned off at the time a Duncan went missing.
口袋里仍然装着他的钱包，里面有他欧洲旅行的必需品，包括他的国际驾照和一张加拿大电话卡。他本应归还给租赁店的滑雪板和滑雪靴也和他在一起。在斯图拜冰川各处，都有类似于发现邓肯尸体的裂缝。为了确保滑雪者的安全，压雪机在每天结束时平整滑雪道，用雪填平每一个裂缝。未平整的区域被封锁，以确保滑雪者不会越界。滑雪缆车操作员坚持认为，在邓肯失踪时，滑雪缆车左右两侧的区域已被封锁。
Cravasses like the one Duncan's body was found in also moved naturally over time. It was therefore deduced that at the time of Duncan's death, the crevasse would have been about 40 metres further uphill, just outside of the designated ski run. Authorities therefore theorised that Duncan could have either ridden off course while snowboarding or been riding the ski lift when he fell off. It wasn't possible to snowboard down the lift route and they assumed Duncan would have thought it was too difficult to climb up. Instead, they concluded that he likely took a shortcut on foot across an out-of-bounds area. The air was thick with fog that day and Duncan could have gotten
像发现邓肯尸体那样的裂缝也会随着时间的推移自然移动。因此推断，在邓肯死亡时，裂缝应该在山上约40米处，就在指定滑雪道之外。因此，当局推测邓肯可能是在滑雪时偏离了路线，或者是在乘坐滑雪缆车时摔了下来。沿着缆车路线滑雪是不可能的，他们认为邓肯会觉得爬上去太难了。相反，他们得出结论，他很可能抄近路步行穿过了一个禁区。那天雾气浓重，邓肯可能在
lost before falling into one of the crevasses too far outside of the ski run for anyone else to notice. Duncan's frozen remains were removed using an ice pick and transported to the coroner, where a pathologist was tasked with formally identifying the body. In Austria, autopsies aren't necessary if the individual is determined to have died as the result of an accident, and as such, no autopsy was requested. Based on the known facts, the pathologist concluded that Duncan had likely fallen into the crevasse and was unable to climb out. He would have managed to breathe some of the air that was trapped in the snow
迷路后掉进了裂缝中，离滑雪道太远，没人能注意到。邓肯冰冻的遗体用冰镐取出，并运送到验尸官那里，由病理学家负责正式鉴定尸体。在奥地利，如果确定个人是因事故死亡，则不需要进行尸检，因此没有要求进行尸检。根据已知事实，病理学家得出结论，邓肯很可能掉进了裂缝中，无法爬出来。他可能设法呼吸了一些困在雪里的空气
for a little while before running out of oxygen and suffocating to death. Bob and Linda MacPherson promptly arrived in Innsbruck to identify Duncan's mummified body. His remains were laid out in the forensic institute, covered in a white sheet with only his face visible. Despite his skin being black from oxidation, Linda recognised her son right away. Bob and Linda each took a moment to say goodbye to their son. If there was any consolation to be found after 14 agonising years, it was that Duncan likely hadn't suffered too badly. The forensic pathologist in charge, Dr Walter Rabel, told the Macphersons that survivors of similar experiences had reported feeling calm and happy in the moments
一段时间，然后耗尽氧气窒息而死。鲍勃和琳达·麦克弗森迅速抵达因斯布鲁克，鉴定邓肯木乃伊化的尸体。他的遗体被安放在法医研究所，盖着白布，只露出脸部。尽管他的皮肤因氧化而变黑，但琳达一眼就认出了她的儿子。鲍勃和琳达各自花了一点时间与儿子告别。如果说在14年的痛苦之后还有什么安慰的话，那就是邓肯可能没有遭受太大的痛苦。负责的法医病理学家沃尔特·拉贝尔博士告诉麦克弗森夫妇，类似经历的幸存者曾报告说在被救出的那一刻感到平静和快乐。
before they were rescued. While the Macphersons were relieved to discover that Duncan hadn't suffered any of their worst-case scenarios, something didn't feel right. A few days after identifying their son, they returned to the Stubai glacier and rode the gondola up the Schaufelferner like they'd done many times before. Two glacier employees then drove them in a snowcat to the location where Duncan's body had been found. While the Macphersons were anticipating the spot to be off to the side in an area that was obviously out of bounds, they were shocked to see that it was right in the middle of the ski run. In fact, they'd passed by that very spot themselves several times over the years.
虽然麦克弗森夫妇得知邓肯没有经历他们最坏的情况感到宽慰，但有些事情感觉不对劲。在鉴定儿子尸体几天后，他们回到了斯图拜冰川，像往常一样乘坐缆车登上Schaufelferner。两名冰川员工随后开着雪地车将他们带到发现邓肯尸体的地方。虽然麦克弗森夫妇预料到那个地点会在一侧，在一个显然是禁区的区域，但他们震惊地发现它就在滑雪道的中间。事实上，多年来他们自己曾多次经过那个地方。
Bob had even taken a photo of Linda standing nearby. It struck them that for all the time they'd spent worrying about their son, thousands of people had been skiing practically right over him. As they tried to get their heads around the reality of it all, Bob looked into the recently disturbed ice and noticed something black emerging from the melting snow. He picked it up. It was a large piece of Duncan's rented snowboard, clearly broken with the serial number still visible. Bob poked around further, and to his utter dismay, he found several of Duncan's bones that the recovery team had failed to retrieve. Appalled by the careless recovery efforts, the McPherson sought answers from Dr Walter
鲍勃甚至拍了一张琳达站在附近的照片。他们意识到，在他们为儿子担心的所有时间里，成千上万的人实际上就在他身上滑雪。当他们试图理解这一切的现实时，鲍勃看向最近被扰动的冰层，注意到融化的雪中冒出了一些黑色的东西。他捡了起来。那是邓肯租来的滑雪板的一大块，明显断裂，序列号清晰可见。鲍勃进一步翻找，令他极度沮丧的是，他发现了邓肯的几块骨头，搜救队没能找回。对粗心的搜救工作感到震惊，麦克弗森夫妇向沃尔特·拉贝尔博士寻求答案。
Rabel, the forensic pathologist. He advised them that some of the items, such as Duncan's snowboard and clothing, had been encased in such a way that it was impossible to remove them using an ice pick. Instead, the rescue crew had used a snow grooming machine to dig them out which had resulted in some damage. Bob was taken aback by this. He was familiar with snow grooming machines and knew that they didn't have any excavation capabilities. The tiller blade on the front, which consists of a rapidly rotating shaft, was used to push snow, not dig ice. Suspicions raised, the Macphersons wanted to have their
法医病理学家。他建议他们，一些物品，如邓肯的滑雪板和衣服，被包裹得无法用冰镐取出。相反，救援队使用了一台雪地平整机将它们挖出来，这导致了一些损坏。鲍勃对此感到吃惊。他熟悉雪地平整机，知道它们没有任何挖掘能力。前面的耕作刀片由一个快速旋转的轴组成，用于推雪，而不是挖冰。怀疑产生后，麦克弗森夫妇想要进行
own autopsy conducted. But repatriating Duncan's body back to Canada was an expensive endeavour, and their relentless search for him had already set them back over 100,000 euros, their entire retirement fund. They simply didn't have the money. Besides, Dr Raabal advised them that given how long Duncan's body had spent in the ice, an autopsy probably wouldn't reveal March anyway. He offered to have a computerised tomography scan done of Duncan's body instead. It would produce two and three dimensional x-ray images of the remains. While it wouldn't reveal how Duncan had died, it would show any injuries he'd sustained. The McPherson's agreed to go ahead with the scan. A few days later, Dr Raabel told them that while he hadn't yet seen the scans himself, a colleague in the radiology department said Duncan hadn't
他们自己的尸检。但将邓肯的尸体运回加拿大是一项昂贵的努力，他们对他不懈的搜寻已经让他们花费了超过10万欧元，这是他们全部的退休基金。他们根本没有钱。此外，拉贝尔博士建议他们，考虑到邓肯的尸体在冰里待了这么久，尸检可能也查不出什么。他提议改为对邓肯的尸体进行计算机断层扫描。它将产生遗体的二维和三维X射线图像。虽然它不会揭示邓肯是如何死亡的，但它会显示他受到的任何伤害。麦克弗森夫妇同意进行扫描。几天后，拉贝尔博士告诉他们，虽然他自己还没有看过扫描结果，但放射科的一位同事说邓肯没有
sustained any major injury that would account for his death, bolstering the theory that he died by suffocation. Reluctantly, his parents accepted the explanation for Duncan's accidental death and consented to have his body cremated. They returned to Canada armed with nothing more than his ashes, his ski boots, and the remnants of his broken snowboard. While Duncan's case was officially closed, that didn't stop his parents from seeking answers. It seemed unbelievable to them that Duncan could have died right at the spot where he was last seen and then gone undetected for so many years. The last reported sighting of Duncan had occurred around 2.30pm on Wednesday August 9, 1989. The slope closed to the public at 4pm, after which the piston bullies came out to groom the snow in preparation for the following day's run.
受到任何会导致他死亡的重大伤害，这支持了他死于窒息的理论。不情愿地，他的父母接受了邓肯意外死亡的解释，并同意将他的尸体火化。他们带着他的骨灰、滑雪靴和破碎滑雪板的残骸回到了加拿大。虽然邓肯的案件正式结案，但这并没有阻止他的父母寻求答案。在他们看来，邓肯可能死在最后一次露面的地方，却多年未被发现，这似乎令人难以置信。最后一次关于邓肯的目击报告发生在1989年8月9日星期三下午2点30分左右。斜坡于下午4点对公众关闭，之后压雪机出来平整雪地，为第二天的滑雪做准备。
What the McPherson's couldn't understand was why didn't anyone go looking for Duncan, despite the fact his car sat in the parking lot, his rental gear hadn't been returned to the ski shop, and his wet clothing sat hanging in Walter Hinterhossel's office. For many years, the Innsbruck police had told the McPherson's there had never been any fatal accidents on the Schaufelferner ski run. But as the McPherson's soon discovered, this wasn't the case. In fact, almost one year to the day before Duncan went missing, international student Chung Yin Chu had been skiing the Schelfl Fairner when he fell from the ski lift. He then took a shortcut across the cordoned off area and fell into a crevasse. Unlike Duncan, Chung was visiting with friends who raised the alarm when he failed to surface at the
麦克弗森夫妇无法理解的是，为什么没有人去寻找邓肯，尽管他的车停在停车场，他的租赁装备没有归还给滑雪店，而且他湿透的衣服挂在沃尔特·辛特霍尔泽的办公室里。多年来，因斯布鲁克警方一直告诉麦克弗森夫妇，Schaufelferner滑雪道上从未发生过致命事故。但正如麦克弗森夫妇很快发现的那样，事实并非如此。事实上，在邓肯失踪前几乎整整一年，国际学生Chung Yin Chu在滑雪时从缆车上摔了下来。他随后抄近路穿过封锁区域，掉进了一个裂缝。与邓肯不同，Chung是和朋友一起来的，当他没能在一天结束时出现时，他们拉响了警报。
end of the day. Rescue workers found Chung in the ice, his body temperature so low that he was barely clinging to life. He was transported to hospital, where he passed away due to complications from hypothermia. During the McPherson's tireless search for Duncan, the possibility that he could have fallen down a crevasse had never once been suggested by officials, even though he was last sighted in the very area where Cheng Yinqiu had died a year earlier. And the same police officer had overseen both searches. Not only did this raise some serious red flags for the Macphersons, they also took issue with the suggestion that if Duncan had fallen off the ski lift he might have found it too difficult to climb back up the slope, and that's
救援人员在冰层中发现了Chung，他的体温极低，几乎无法维持生命。他被送往医院，因体温过低引起的并发症而去世。在麦克弗森夫妇为邓肯进行的不懈搜寻中，官员们从未建议过他可能掉进裂缝的可能性，尽管他最后一次露面的地方正是Cheng Yinqiu一年前死亡的地方。而且同一名警官监督了两次搜寻。这不仅为麦克弗森夫妇敲响了严重的警钟，他们还对以下建议表示异议：如果邓肯从缆车上摔下来，他可能会觉得爬回斜坡太难了，这就是
why he took the shortcut through the cordoned off area. Duncan was a fit, strong professional athlete who was also very safety conscious. Back in 1993, snowboarding instructor Walter Hinterhossel had even told the German television show Bitter Melde die G, that Duncan had been particularly cautious around the slope boundaries. So, if he had indeed fallen off the ski lifts, the McPherson's found it hard to believe that he would have taken the risky shortcut instead of simply climbing back up the mountain. In September 2003, the Innsbruck Police released their final official report into Duncan McPherson's death.
为什么他抄近路穿过封锁区域。邓肯是一位健康、强壮的职业运动员，也非常注重安全。早在1993年，滑雪教练沃尔特·辛特霍尔泽甚至告诉德国电视节目《Bitter Melde die G》，邓肯在斜坡边界附近特别谨慎。所以，如果他确实从缆车上摔了下来，麦克弗森夫妇很难相信他会选择冒险的捷径，而不是简单地爬回山上。2003年9月，因斯布鲁克警方发布了关于邓肯·麦克弗森死亡的最终官方报告。
While they acknowledged that they could only speculate about the cause of the accident, a statement from the police read, Mountain accidents, primarily falls into crevasses or ice breaks in glacier areas, happen regularly. Staying on the glacier outside of the secured ski area without appropriate safety equipment carries, among other things, a high risk of falling into a crevasse. Such accidents are almost always the result of careless behaviour on the part of those involved. The Macphersons were eager to see the results of Duncan's computerised tomography scan for themselves, but it took them several months of going back and forth with Dr Walter Rabel in Innsbruck before they finally got a hold of them. The scan left Bob and Linda stunned.
虽然他们承认只能推测事故原因，但警方的一份声明写道：“山地事故，主要是掉进裂缝或冰川区域的冰裂缝，经常发生。在没有适当安全设备的情况下留在安全滑雪区之外的冰川上，除其他外，具有掉进裂缝的高风险。此类事故几乎总是由于相关人员的粗心行为造成的。”麦克弗森夫妇渴望亲自查看邓肯计算机断层扫描的结果，但他们与因斯布鲁克的沃尔特·拉贝尔博士来回沟通了几个月才最终拿到。扫描结果让鲍勃和琳达惊呆了。
Despite being told that Duncan hadn't sustained any fatal injuries, it appeared on the scan that he'd been decapitated. Both of his forearms were fractured and had been completely separated from his body. His left leg also appeared to have been amputated in two places, and the lower part of his left leg was completely shattered. Dr. Rabel explained that the injuries to Duncan's forearms likely occurred when he fell into the crevasse and presumably tried to break his fall. As for the other injuries, he said these had been caused by the natural movement of the ice over the years. He'd examined many corpses that had been stuck in glaciers and had observed similar injuries, with the glacier essentially breaking up the bodies over time.
尽管被告知邓肯没有受到任何致命伤害，但扫描显示他似乎被斩首了。他的双前臂骨折，并已完全与身体分离。他的左腿似乎也在两个地方被截肢，左腿下部完全粉碎。拉贝尔博士解释说，邓肯前臂的伤害很可能发生在他掉进裂缝并推测试图减缓坠落时。至于其他伤害，他说这些是由多年来冰层的自然运动造成的。他检查过许多被困在冰川中的尸体，并观察到了类似的伤害，冰川本质上随着时间的推移将尸体分解了。
Linda and Bob weren't convinced. Eager to get all the information they could, they successfully petitioned to get a copy of the 2003 case file from Canadian Foreign Affairs. Reports and photos of the recovery mission revealed that Duncan's body had been retrieved by two Stubai Glacier employees with their rescue workers hovering in a helicopter overhead. No police officers or a coroner were present. Not only did this seem grossly inadequate, the photos of Duncan's body as it lay in the ice also raised some serious questions. Firstly, Duncan's body lay horizontally on its left-hand side, not vertically like most people who die from similar falls. His left leg was completely
琳达和鲍勃并不信服。渴望获得他们能得到的所有信息，他们成功请愿获得了加拿大外交部2003年的案件档案副本。救援任务的报告和照片显示，邓肯的尸体是由两名斯图拜冰川员工找回的，救援人员在头顶的直升机上盘旋。没有警察或验尸官在场。这不仅看起来极其不充分，邓肯尸体躺在冰里的照片也引发了一些严重的问题。首先，邓肯的尸体水平躺在左侧，而不是像大多数死于类似坠落的人那样垂直。他的左腿完全
shattered while his right leg which lay directly on top of the left, was perfectly intact. If the damage to Duncan's body was caused by the natural movement of the ice over the years, how could one leg be fine and the other so badly damaged? The Macphersons were also told that damage to Duncan's clothing and snowboard had been done during the recovery process, but it was clear from the photos that this wasn't the case. Some of his clothing was already torn to shreds and bunched together in a way that didn't look like a natural occurrence. Duncan's left ski boot also sat by his side, perfectly intact and filled with snow.
粉碎，而直接压在左腿上的右腿却完好无损。如果邓肯身体的损坏是由多年来冰层的自然运动造成的，怎么可能一条腿没事，另一条腿却损坏得如此严重？麦克弗森夫妇还被告知，邓肯衣服和滑雪板的损坏是在回收过程中造成的，但从照片中可以清楚地看出事实并非如此。他的一些衣服已经被撕成碎片，并以一种看起来不像自然发生的方式堆在一起。邓肯的左滑雪靴也放在他身边，完好无损，里面装满了雪。
Its insular lining was found elsewhere, shredded and covered with V-shaped puncture marks, consistent with the damage to his left leg. This meant that Duncan hadn't been wearing the boots at the time he died, which meant he'd unstrapped them from his snowboard. The Macphersons wondered whether he could have survived the fall into the crevasse and had enough room to take the boots off and attempt to climb out. But if that had been the case, the boots would have gone further down into the crevasse, not remained right next to his body. gone further down into the crevasse, not remained right next to his body. But what really shocked the McPhersons was the snowboard itself. When they'd been given the broken board, red paint marks were visible in the wood, which had been explained as having occurred
它的绝缘衬里在其他地方被发现，被撕碎并覆盖着V形穿孔痕迹，与他左腿的损坏一致。这意味着邓肯在死亡时没有穿靴子，这意味着他已经把它们从滑雪板上解开了。麦克弗森夫妇想知道他是否可能在掉进裂缝后幸存下来，并有足够的空间脱掉靴子并试图爬出来。但如果是那样的话，靴子会掉进裂缝更深处，而不是留在他的尸体旁边。但真正让麦克弗森夫妇震惊的是滑雪板本身。当他们拿到那块断裂的板子时，木头上可以看到红色的油漆痕迹，这被解释为在
during the recovery mission. Examining the photos, the McPhersons could see that the red paint marks were visible on the snowboard when Duncan's body was initially found, indicating that damage had occurred earlier on. Bob retrieved the broken snowboard from his basement and examined it closely. He noticed that the damaged parts of the board featured the exact same amount of heavy weathering and rust as the undamaged parts. The only explanation Bob could find for this was that the board must have been broken and exposed to the elements long before the recovery in 2003. And if the board had been torn up by machinery before it was buried in the ice, then what did this mean for Duncan? The McPherson sent the scans to a medical
回收任务中发生的。检查照片，麦克弗森夫妇可以看到，当邓肯的尸体最初被发现时，滑雪板上就可以看到红色的油漆痕迹，表明损坏发生得更早。鲍勃从地下室取回了破碎的滑雪板并仔细检查。他注意到板子的损坏部分与未损坏部分具有完全相同程度的严重风化和锈迹。鲍勃能找到的唯一解释是，板子一定在2003年回收之前很久就已经断裂并暴露在自然环境中。如果板子在被埋入冰层之前就被机器撕碎了，那么这对邓肯意味着什么？麦克弗森夫妇将扫描结果发送给了一位加拿大的医疗
professional in Canada who raised the possibility that Duncan might have been run over by a snow-grimming machine. Two renowned forensic experts who had first-hand experience in examining corpses that had been retrieved from the ice independently agreed. The damage to Duncan's body wasn't caused by movements in the glacier, but by contact with heavy machinery. by movements in the glacier, but by contact with heavy machinery. In Innsbruck, Dr Walter Rabel discounted this possibility. He said that such an incident wouldn't have severed Duncan's limbs, but caused damage to his ribs, pelvis and organs. It also didn't explain how he'd ended up in the crevasse. If Duncan was run over by a snow-grooming machine, Dr. Rabel said someone would have had to drive back and push him into
专业人士，他提出了邓肯可能被雪地平整机碾过的可能性。两位在检查从冰层中找回的尸体方面有第一手经验的著名法医专家独立同意了这一点。邓肯身体的损坏不是由冰川运动造成的，而是由与重型机械的接触造成的。在因斯布鲁克，沃尔特·拉贝尔博士否定了这种可能性。他说，这样的事件不会切断邓肯的四肢，而是会对他造成肋骨、骨盆和器官的损伤。这也无法解释他是如何掉进裂缝的。如果邓肯被雪地平整机碾过，拉贝尔博士说，有人必须在事后开车回来并把他推入
the crevasse after the fact. Bob and Delinda had always been dubious about the claim that no snowboards had been missing from the rental shop on the afternoon Duncan went missing. They noted that while Duncan's international driver's license and calling card had been returned to them, his Canadian driver's license had not. They wondered whether this was because Duncan had left the license with the rental shop as a deposit for his equipment, along with his shoes, which also hadn't been returned to his family. When Duncan failed to return at the end of the day, someone got rid of the license, his shoes, and any record of his hire. If this was the case, it meant something had to have happened to Duncan on Wednesday August 9
裂缝中。鲍勃和琳达一直对邓肯失踪那天下午租赁店没有丢失滑雪板的说法持怀疑态度。他们注意到，虽然邓肯的国际驾照和电话卡已经退还给他们，但他的加拿大驾照却没有。他们想知道这是不是因为邓肯把驾照留在了租赁店作为设备押金，连同他的鞋子一起，这些也没有退还给他的家人。当邓肯在一天结束时没有回来时，有人处理掉了驾照、他的鞋子以及任何租赁记录。如果是这样，这意味着邓肯在8月9日星期三一定发生了什么事，
that Stubai Glacier personnel were aware of. A Glacier official claimed that the Cordondorf area had been searched during the initial search in late September 1989, but it had been snowing at the time and therefore the crevasse Duncan was in would have been covered with snow. Bob and Linda had been there at the time in question. It hadn't been snowing, nor was there any fresh snow on the ground. Stubai Glacier staff also claimed that on the day Duncan went missing, all known crevasses on the ski run had been filled in, and those that hadn't had been cordoned off. The police had taken photos of the Schaufelferner ski run during the search for Duncan in 1989, but despite numerous requests
斯图拜冰川的工作人员是知道的。一位冰川官员声称，在1989年9月下旬的初步搜寻中，封锁区域已被搜查过，但当时正在下雪，因此邓肯所在的裂缝会被雪覆盖。鲍勃和琳达当时就在现场。当时并没有下雪，地上也没有新雪。斯图拜冰川的工作人员还声称，在邓肯失踪的那天，滑雪道上所有已知的裂缝都已被填平，而那些没有填平的都已被封锁。警方在1989年搜寻邓肯期间拍摄了Schaufelferner滑雪道的照片，但尽管多次请求
from Duncan's family, they refused to hand these over. Without the photos, there was no way to know for sure if the dangerous areas had indeed been cordoned off. Convinced that something more sinister than a tragic accident was at play, the McPherson's made multiple efforts to have Duncan's case reinvestigated. made multiple efforts to have Duncan's case reinvestigated. But Innsbruck police maintained that it was an open and shut accidental death and the case would remain closed. Over the following years, the Macphersons tried everything they could think of to have Duncan's case reviewed. They filed numerous complaints with the Austrian authorities, submitted a formal complaint to the Ministry of Justice and even tried their luck with the European Court of Human Rights.
来自邓肯的家人，他们拒绝交出这些照片。没有照片，就无法确定危险区域是否确实已被封锁。麦克弗森夫妇确信这不仅仅是一场悲剧性的事故，背后隐藏着更险恶的阴谋，于是多次努力要求重新调查邓肯的案件。但因斯布鲁克警方坚持认为这是一起结案的意外死亡事件，案件将保持关闭。在接下来的几年里，麦克弗森夫妇尝试了他们能想到的一切方法来要求复审邓肯的案件。他们向奥地利当局提出了无数次投诉，向司法部提交了正式申诉，甚至还尝试向欧洲人权法院寻求帮助。
All of their appeals were rejected. Refusing to let it go, Bob and Linda began working with California-based author John Leake, who had taken an interest in Duncan's case. John had lived in Austria while investigating the crimes of serial killer Jack Unterweger as covered in episode 197 of Casefile, and he had a good understanding of Austrian culture. John spent several years getting to know the Mcphersons and the intricate details of their story. After reviewing all of the evidence for himself, John consulted with numerous specialists, including Dick Pennamen, an American expert in ski slope accidents. Dick took one look at the snowboard and injuries to Duncan's leg and immediately knew the damage was caused by
他们所有的上诉都被驳回了。鲍勃和琳达不愿放弃，开始与居住在加州的作家约翰·利克合作，他对邓肯的案件产生了兴趣。约翰在调查连环杀手杰克·温特韦格的罪行时曾居住在奥地利（该案件在《案件档案》第197集中有报道），他对奥地利文化有很好的了解。约翰花了几年时间深入了解麦克弗森夫妇及其故事的错综复杂细节。在亲自审查了所有证据后，约翰咨询了多位专家，其中包括美国滑雪场事故专家迪克·彭纳曼。迪克看了一眼滑雪板和邓肯腿部的伤势，立刻意识到这些伤害是由
a snow grooming tiller. Not only are the bones broken in pieces, Dick explained, but the flesh around the bones has also been chopped up. A crevasse four could break bones, but it couldn't grind meat. Given that Duncan's boots were no longer on his feet, the theory was raised that he might have fallen into the crevasse, survived the fall, and then managed to climb out on his own. While he was hanging on the edge with one hand and a leg, the snow groomer came along and drove over him, mangling the exposed limb before burying him in the ice. But if Duncan's body had only been mangled and not fully run over, it raised the question of how Duncan's body and his snowboarding equipment ended up so deep into the crevasse and not just on the surface.
扫雪机的旋耕机造成的。迪克解释说，不仅骨头被撞碎了，骨头周围的肉也被绞碎了。冰川裂缝可能会导致骨折，但无法将肉绞碎。鉴于邓肯的靴子已经不在脚上，有人提出了这样一种理论：他可能掉进了裂缝，在坠落中幸存下来，然后设法自己爬了出来。当他用一只手和一条腿挂在边缘时，扫雪机经过并从他身上碾过，在将他埋入冰层之前绞碎了他暴露的肢体。但如果邓肯的尸体只是被绞碎而没有被完全碾过，这就提出了一个问题：为什么邓肯的尸体和他的滑雪装备会深入裂缝，而不是仅仅留在表面。
As far as Dick Penerman was concerned, not one but two separate events had resulted in Duncan's death. An alternative theory was that Duncan could have suffered an injury, perhaps a broken leg, which would explain why he unstrapped his board and took his left boot off. Perhaps he was lying in a semi-fetal position as he waited for help to arrive, unable to walk himself. Unable to see him through the fog, a snow groomer accidentally hit him, dragging his limbs into the tiller and killing him. Realising what they'd done and the impact this would have on tourism, one or more employees removed his body from the tiller. They threw Duncan's body in the crevasse, which was concealed with snow.
在迪克·彭纳曼看来，导致邓肯死亡的不是一起，而是两起独立的事件。另一种理论是，邓肯可能受了伤，比如腿部骨折，这解释了他为什么要解开滑雪板并脱掉左脚靴子。也许他正蜷缩在半胎儿姿势等待救援，无法自行行走。由于大雾看不见他，扫雪机意外撞到了他，将他的肢体拖入旋耕机中致其死亡。意识到他们所做的事情以及这对旅游业的影响，一名或多名员工将他的尸体从旋耕机中移走。他们把邓肯的尸体扔进了裂缝，并用雪掩盖了痕迹。
The Macphersons took their concerns to the Canadian Broadcasting Corporation, who aired two episodes about Duncan's case for the long-running investigative documentary programme, The Fifth Estate. Speaking about the possibility of third party involvement, John Leake said, "...how did this wreck on the surface of the slope wind up in a neat package in a shallow crevasse? Those two actions do not go together, and I've talked to 20 different people who know glaciers and crevasses and physics and everything else, and no one can explain to me how those two things can happen without an intermediate action of someone. Canadian high school teacher Judy Wigmore was watching the show when it occurred
麦克弗森夫妇将他们的担忧告诉了加拿大广播公司，该公司为长期播出的调查纪录片节目《第五阶层》播出了两集关于邓肯案件的节目。在谈到第三方介入的可能性时，约翰·利克说：“……这个在斜坡表面的残骸怎么会整齐地出现在浅裂缝中？这两个动作是不相容的，我与20位了解冰川、裂缝、物理学及其他相关知识的人交谈过，没有人能向我解释在没有他人中间干预的情况下，这两件事是如何发生的。”加拿大高中教师朱迪·威格莫尔在观看节目时突然想到
to her that she'd been skiing on the Stubai glacier with her family on the very same day that Duncan went missing. As far as Judy recalled, there had been no signs or barriers on the ski run to indicate any potential dangers. If she'd known about the crevasse hazards, she would have never let her children go skiing there. Unsettled by this thought, Judy tracked down her old travel notes from Wednesday, August 9, 1989. She had recorded the conditions that day as being, quote, the conditions that day as being quote, pretty awful, mostly whiteout and slushy snow. Judy wrote that it was so overcast they could hardly see the mountains.
她在邓肯失踪的当天曾和家人在斯图拜冰川滑雪。据朱迪回忆，滑雪道上没有任何标志或障碍物来指示任何潜在的危险。如果她知道裂缝的危险，她绝不会让她的孩子们去那里滑雪。被这个想法困扰，朱迪翻出了她1989年8月9日星期三的旧旅行笔记。她记录了当天的状况，引用如下：“当天的状况相当糟糕，大部分时间是白茫茫一片，雪地泥泞。”朱迪写道，当时阴天，他们几乎看不见山脉。
She also recalled that the ski shop had been very disorganised and it had been a challenge to get her whole family outfitted for the day. Judy reached out to Bob and Linda MacPherson with this information and sent them the few photos that she'd snapped on the ski run that day. The ski lift on the main hill where Duncan was last seen was clearly visible in one of them. There was no fence or cordoned off area to be seen. There was no fence or cordoned off area to be seen. After researching Duncan's case for several years, John Leake released his findings in a book titled Cold A Long Time, An Alpine Mystery. John ultimately believed that Stubai Glacier personnel likely knew from the get-go that Duncan had died in a crevasse on Wednesday August 9, 1989, but had withheld this information, knowing that his parents would have demanded a wide-scale excavation of the crevasses until their son was found.
她还回忆说，滑雪店非常混乱，为全家人准备当天的装备是一项挑战。朱迪带着这些信息联系了鲍勃和琳达·麦克弗森，并寄给了他们几张她在当天滑雪时拍的照片。其中一张照片清晰可见邓肯最后一次露面的主山滑雪缆车。照片中没有看到任何围栏或封锁区域。在研究了邓肯的案件几年后，约翰·利克发布了他的调查结果，书名为《寒冷许久：高山之谜》。约翰最终认为，斯图拜冰川的工作人员很可能从一开始就知道邓肯在1989年8月9日星期三死于裂缝中，但隐瞒了这一信息，因为他们知道他的父母会要求对裂缝进行大规模挖掘，直到找到他们的儿子。
Not wanting to shut the glacier down in the middle of peak season or suffer the bad publicity that would go with it, they said Duncan had returned his rental equipment to cover up the truth and redirect the investigations elsewhere. While it was possible that only the driver of the snow groomer and perhaps some of his co-workers knew exactly how the disaster happened, John wrote, After systematically analysing the facts with Dick Peneman, we realised that only one conclusion could be drawn. Someone had intentionally concealed Duncan's body in the crevasse. The Macphersons contemplated taking legal action against the Stubai Glacier, but were dissuaded by both the Innsbruck pathologist and some independent lawyers.
由于不想在旺季关闭冰川，也不想遭受随之而来的负面宣传，他们声称邓肯已经归还了租赁设备，以掩盖真相并将调查引向别处。约翰写道，虽然可能只有扫雪机司机和他的部分同事确切知道灾难是如何发生的，但在与迪克·彭纳曼系统地分析了事实后，我们意识到只能得出一个结论。有人故意将邓肯的尸体藏在裂缝中。麦克弗森夫妇曾考虑对斯图拜冰川采取法律行动，但被因斯布鲁克的病理学家和一些独立律师劝阻了。
Because the exact cause of Duncan's death remained unclear, they were told there was little chance of proving any misconduct by the Stubai Glacier staff. Instead, they sought reimbursement from the Stubai glacier founder Heinrich Klier for the costs they'd incurred during their search for Duncan, on the basis that his employees had given them misleading information. Their claim was rejected by Klier's insurance provider, who stated the glacier company was not at fault for their son's death. While Bob and Linda ultimately accepted that whatever happened to Duncan had been an accident, they believed that both the Stubai Glacier staff and Innsbruck police had acted negligently.
由于邓肯的确切死因仍不清楚，他们被告知几乎没有机会证明斯图拜冰川员工存在任何不当行为。相反，他们向斯图拜冰川的创始人海因里希·克里尔寻求报销他们在寻找邓肯期间产生的费用，理由是他的员工向他们提供了误导性信息。他们的索赔被克里尔的保险公司拒绝了，保险公司称冰川公司对他们儿子的死亡没有过错。虽然鲍勃和琳达最终接受了邓肯遭遇的是一场意外，但他们认为斯图拜冰川的工作人员和因斯布鲁克警方都存在疏忽行为。
Not only had this caused the McPherson's 14 years of undue angst and financial hardship, it also put the lives of other skiers at risk. Linda told a journalist for German magazine, Datum, "...the only crime for us is the way in which this case was investigated. When asked on the fifth estate how she would react if someone finally came forward and took accountability, Linda responded, "...I don't think I'd be able to speak. I'd just be so happy that I'd cry. It would restore my faith in humanity." inhumanity. August 2024 marked the 35-year anniversary of Duncan McPherson's death. Bob and Linda are now in their 80s and they remain convinced that Duncan's death was covered up to protect the Stubai Valley's valuable tourism industry. While they have come to accept that they will never get the justice they so desperately
这不仅给麦克弗森夫妇带来了14年的过度焦虑和经济困难，还使其他滑雪者的生命处于危险之中。琳达告诉德国杂志《Datum》的一名记者：“……对我们来说，唯一的罪行是这个案件的调查方式。”当在《第五阶层》节目中被问及如果有人最终站出来承担责任她会有什么反应时，琳达回答说：“……我想我无法说话。我会因为太高兴而哭泣。这会恢复我对人类的信心。”2024年8月是邓肯·麦克弗森去世35周年。鲍勃和琳达现在已经80多岁了，他们仍然坚信邓肯的死是为了保护斯图拜谷宝贵的旅游业而被掩盖的。虽然他们已经接受了他们永远无法得到他们如此渴望的正义，
desire from officials in Austria, they still refuse to stay quiet. In August 2024, Linda told CTV News that without anyone coming forward to take responsibility, quote, "...my next and only choice is to expose the corruption. I won't quit. There's always a way to move it along. A British documentary about Duncan's case is supposedly in the works, with the couple vowing to continue their quest for justice until they die.
从奥地利官员那里得到正义，但他们仍然拒绝保持沉默。2024年8月，琳达告诉CTV新闻，在没有人站出来承担责任的情况下，她说：“……我的下一个也是唯一的选择就是揭露腐败。我不会放弃。总有办法推动它。”据称，一部关于邓肯案件的英国纪录片正在制作中，这对夫妇发誓要继续追求正义，直到他们去世。
While it's essential for Linda that someone be held accountable for the failures in her son's case, she only has to think of Duncan's warm and generous nature to be reminded of the good in people. When Linda had arrived in Innsbruck to identify her son's remains, she asked for a moment alone with him. Looking at Duncan's face she knew straight away that something wasn't right, but she focused on farewelling him as best she could. Linda told Duncan, know you had a good life and you died doing something you loved. And that gives me some peace. I can hear the explosions, I didn't know what was happening. I'm Vicki Petratus.
虽然对琳达来说，有人为她儿子案件中的失误负责至关重要，但她只需想到邓肯温暖而慷慨的天性，就会想起人们善良的一面。当琳达抵达因斯布鲁克辨认她儿子的遗体时，她要求与他单独待一会儿。看着邓肯的脸，她立刻知道有些不对劲，但她专注于尽可能好地送别他。琳达告诉邓肯：“我知道你度过了美好的一生，你死于你热爱的事情。这给了我一些平静。”我能听到爆炸声，我不知道发生了什么。我是薇琪·佩特拉图斯。
And I'm Emily Webb. We are true crime authors and podcasters with a long history of interviewing people who've experienced unthinkable events. The next guy had this Molotov cocktail in his hand and I just saw him lighting it. Are you listening? Pay attention. We're at Link Cafe. A gentleman has taken us hostage.
我是艾米丽·韦伯。我们是真实犯罪作家和播客主持人，有着采访经历过不可思议事件的人的悠久历史。下一个人手里拿着莫洛托夫鸡尾酒，我看到他点燃了它。你在听吗？注意。我们在Link咖啡馆。一位绅士把我们劫持为人质了。
He's got a gun and he's got a bomb. But he turned towards me and he had this demonic look on his face and just came at me. These stories will have you on the edge of your seats. My shieldman wasn't there anymore. It was me by myself. I had no protection.
他有一把枪，还有一个炸弹。但他转向我，脸上带着恶魔般的表情，直接向我冲来。这些故事会让你坐立不安。我的盾牌手不在那里了。是我自己。我没有任何保护。
We are going to die now. Who could get out of that situation? I could hear explosions. I didn't know what was happening. It's just a matter of self-preservation. Get myself out of there. We get to ask questions that most would never ask. And because of that, we get told things most would never hear about.
我们现在要死了。谁能从那种情况下逃脱？我能听到爆炸声。我不知道发生了什么。这只是自我保护的问题。让自己从那里逃出来。我们有机会问大多数人永远不会问的问题。正因为如此，我们被告知了大多数人永远不会听到的事情。
And I couldn't get my gun out, I'm sort of fighting with him. He's stabbing me. Maybe he just hit his head on the ground when he went down, maybe he's okay. I saw that she wasn't in a very good way. Yeah, this will be difficult for me to talk about. What draws us to these stories is the strength of the people coming out the other side of what they've been through. But it was eight years before I processed what happened in the siege.
我无法拔出枪，我正在和他搏斗。他在刺我。也许他倒下时头撞到了地上，也许他没事。我看到她的情况不太好。是的，这对我来说很难谈论。吸引我们关注这些故事的是人们在经历过这些事情后展现出的力量。但在我处理在围攻中发生的事情之前，已经过去了八年。
There is a way. It's not going to be easy. You might have pitfalls, but you've got to keep going. I'm not going to let it beat me or defy me. So even though these are stories of the unthinkable, they are also stories of hope. You've got to be the best for you first before you can be the best for someone else. The unthinkable is available now.
总有办法。这不会容易。你可能会遇到陷阱，但你必须继续前进。我不会让它打败我或击垮我。所以，尽管这些是关于不可思议事件的故事，但它们也是关于希望的故事。你必须先成为最好的自己，才能成为别人的最好。不可思议现在已经上线。
Be sure to download and follow the unthinkable wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, Torontonians. Recycling is more than a routine. It's a vital responsibility. By recycling properly, you help conserve resources, reduce energy use and greenhouse gas emissions, and protect the environment. Toronto's Blue Bin Recycling Program ensures the majority of the right items are recovered and transformed into new products.
请务必下载并关注“不可思议”，无论你在哪里收听播客。嘿，多伦多人。回收不仅仅是一种例行公事。这是一项至关重要的责任。通过正确回收，你可以帮助节约资源、减少能源使用和温室气体排放，并保护环境。多伦多的蓝色垃圾桶回收计划确保了大部分正确的物品被回收并转化为新产品。
Recycling rate is important and impactful. Let's work together and make a difference, because small actions lead to big change. For more tips on recycling, visit toronto.ca slash recycle right. Did you know 66% of utility damage is caused by not requesting a locate? Don't let your project become part of this statistic. A quick locate request can save you from unexpected downtime, financial penalties, and keep you safe.
回收率既重要又有影响力。让我们共同努力，做出改变，因为小行动会带来大变化。有关回收的更多提示，请访问toronto.ca斜杠recycle right。你知道吗？66%的公用设施损坏是由于未请求定位造成的。不要让你的项目成为这个统计数据的一部分。快速的定位请求可以让你免受意外停机、经济处罚，并确保你的安全。
Don't let avoidable damage cost you time and money. Click before you dig. Ensure your next project is safe. Visit ontarioonecall.ca. It's free, it's easy, it's the law. Data sourced from the ORCGA 2023 DIRT Report. Can indigenous ways of knowing help kids cope with online bullying? At the University of British Columbia, we believe that they can.
不要让可避免的损坏浪费你的时间和金钱。挖掘前请点击。确保你的下一个项目是安全的。访问ontarioonecall.ca。它是免费的，简单的，这是法律。数据来源自ORCGA 2023 DIRT报告。原住民的认知方式能帮助孩子应对网络欺凌吗？在不列颠哥伦比亚大学，我们相信他们可以。
Dr. Johanna Sam and her team are researching how both Indigenous and non-Indigenous youth cope with cyberaggression, working to bridge the diversity gap in child psychology research. At UBC, our researchers are answering today's most pressing questions. To learn how we're moving the world forward, visit ubc.ca slash forward happens here. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
乔安娜·萨姆博士和她的团队正在研究原住民和非原住民青年如何应对网络攻击，致力于弥合儿童心理学研究中的多样性差距。在UBC，我们的研究人员正在回答当今最紧迫的问题。要了解我们如何推动世界前进，请访问ubc.ca斜杠forward happens here。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。